it's a public holiday thank you for
coming and spending the afternoon with
me this this is a workshop like a new a
new workshop that this is only the
second time I've given it given it
publicly and I'm rereading the material
I'm preparing for I'm really excited
about the things I things I have to
share
so there needs to be a little bit of
explanation about where this where this
workshop came from a couple years I had
this years ago I had this idea and tweet
size being what they were was called
three rules for dating my codebase like
if there are only three rules of things
that I'd like to agree on when we work
together this this would be then of
course the next day I was like oh I
forgot it there is three more and it
probably it probably could have kept
going on for sometime I said so there's
this idea of like like what are the what
are the like like the bullet points of
good go code we're kind of floating
around in my head at the same time or
perhaps of a few years earlier I talked
to a Riley about about writing a book on
go but it kind of fizzled out for two
reasons a rise document presentation
preparation system is pretty good but
it's it wasn't as flexible as I wanted
and I felt like if I was going to be
spending hours and weeks and months of
my day like preparing this document
there are a lot of kind of undefined
steps like like like the the O'Reilly
system you would upload a document but
one started digging into it with you
editor they're like oh yeah we copy that
into something else and then we we added
it ourselves and I didn't like that I
was like well I'm gonna put all the time
into writing this document I want to
have control of my words and then there
was the more unfortunate calculus of
just how much time it was going to take
I'm not going to put bill on the bill on
the spot and ask him how many hours he
spent on his book what reading online
people spend 500 hours he Gore garlic
who did a book on HTTP said he's he
because he's very meticulous kept
meticulous record and he said he spent
nine hundred and eighty one hours that's
three-quarters of a year and the problem
is that if you don't finish the book
there's no partial credit
maybe O'Reilly or whichever publisher is
going to rehome your book and maybe
eventually it makes it struggles out
onto the market and
I think that the difficulty was that
this felt like an old-world way of
software development like where you'd
have architects who would say this is
this is how we're going to write the
software and it's going to take 18
months to implement that it's going to
be in testing and validation for six
months and then it's going to be in like
this waterfall way of developing
software is discredited yet this is
exactly how books are written and so
this workshop the document you're
reading the talks that I give the blog
post that I have is kind of my my hack
my life hack on how to write a book that
you get partial credit for by people
come people can get the value I can get
feedback earlier and I can stop at any
time and nothing is lost also this this
document is liberally licensed feel free
to to link it to reference it to like to
take bits and blog blog about it if you
come from other countries take it home
and give it up your local meetups
however you want it's open source free
as in beer
and the other thing I want to mention
before we get started is that the more
that I research and I read I read the
texts about programming written in the
60s and 70s and the 80s like trying to
find some truth like what is the
absolute truth like what is the one way
to write good software the more I find
that there are no rules in fact the the
deeper you get the less certain I feel
about everything
um and one way I kind of rationalized
this this realization is so Malcolm
Gladwell I think wrote about this kind
of 10,000 hour rule you know to become
proficient in anything and the thing is
it isn't just about like you could you
could become a Star Trek fan by watching
10,000 hours of Star Trek but could you
write a new Star Trek well you probably
have a start at it like you you read all
the reference material but do you have
any practice in writing do you have any
practice in editing editing scripts and
that feedback so I think one of the
takeaways is is yes it might be 10,000
hours but you spend it equal parts
learning and researching and equal parts
practicing and doing that's very much
how it works in the mechanical
mechanical ways and that that's what I
think ultimately contributes to what you
call experience so with that these are
my experiences these are things that
I've tried to distill of the things that
have worked for me or the way that the
realizations I've had um but it's it's
not prescriptive like like like feel
free to disagree feel free to pick and
choose like like you it nothing is lost
if you disagree with one point but you
find value in the others
so the subtitle of this document is best
practices in a programming language and
so if I'm going to use an absolutist
word like best like if this is the best
and everything else it's not as best or
worse then I need some kind of framework
to say what we what I mean by that
Brian control gave a really interesting
presentation not actually about program
languages it was about operating systems
and talking about the guiding principles
of different operating system projects
and the the the summation of that is
different operating systems have
different core values and he makes that
he makes that the the somewhat implement
point that OpenBSD care only about
security everything else is secondary
but that the the the point there is not
that they discard every other every
other possible goal like usability or
performance it's when you have to choose
you have to choose a core set of goal
core set of principles and so what then
do I think are some principles that
define how I think about go and to give
some background about this is a this is
a quote that Russ Cox I think gave it go
for Khan Singapore last year he
certainly been certain to be making the
rounds and it's his observation
paraphrased from his coworker titus
winters that software engineering is
what happens to programming when you add
time and other programmers I mean he's
making a decision between a distinction
between programming and software
engineering programming is typing on a
keyboard it's writing a program to do a
particular thing as for writing a
throwaway script it's writing some some
SQL to do a data transformation it's a
single-use job that does users a
computer for one time does its job and
it's over engineering is oh it has a
component of time for the software
projects that you work on people are
going to join people are going to leave
teams gonna grow and shrink you're going
to get your requirements
features going to be added bugs going to
be fixed this is what this is what
underpins software engineering so if we
say that the underlying goal is good
software engineering then what are some
of the principles that go brings to the
table and I'm going to make the case
that they are clarity simplicity and
productivity now as you see I you know
what I didn't say performance or
concurrency there are some languages
which probably on paper are a little bit
faster than go but then all as simple as
go I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna just
pick on rust and see for that the
languages which make concurrency their
highest or like Erlang everything you do
is concurrency but I argue they're not
as clear that I was readable and
ultimately the the productivity that
engineers get from them is is lower so
let's dig into these a little bit
code is read many many more times than
it is written a single piece of code
over its lifetime if you consider if you
consider something like the standard
library or common a common library or
even just a library that is used inside
your company every single programmer in
that company is going to read the source
of that several times at least versus
the number of people actually
contributed it to it over time
so if you're writing a program for
yourself maybe it only has to run once
the only ever program you're the only
person who's ever going to see it
just do it ever the hell you want it
doesn't matter
like like nobody else has to maintain
this throwaway script but if it's a
piece of software that's going to be
used for more that used by more than one
person used over a long enough time and
that the requirements are going to
change the environment it runs in we're
going to change then fundamentally
fundamentally your goal for this program
must be that is maintainable so the
second the second goal is probably the
one that people think about the most
when they think about go which is
simplicity why why do we care about
simplicity why it's important that we
place this goal above others
[Music]
I think it's fair to say that we've all
been in situations where you say I've
looked at this code I can't understand
it I can't understand it I'm sure many
of you have been in the situation where
you've been asked to maintain a piece of
code and you looked at it you're like I
understand well that's doing I'm pretty
sure if I touch it I'm going to break it
it's the part you don't understand
it's a pie you don't know how to fix and
this is fundamentally complexity
complexity is what turns reliable
software into unreliable software
complexity is what ultimately kills
software projects if you can't read it
you can't maintain it and if you can't
maintain it your only choice is to
replace it so simplicity must be one of
our highest goals whatever programs we
write we should be able to at least
agree that they are simple now how how
you define that in the absolute gonna be
for interpretation but the opposite of
simplicity is complexity if people say I
can't ascend that it's too complex
that's a problem
I love this quote from sandy Matt's
design is the art of arranging code to
work today and to be changeable forever
and that's kind of under underlies what
I think is the the final principle of of
go productivity now it's it's kind of
out of out of place because like like
simplicity clarity like their words we
understand productivity is kind of like
like a like a thing that you do I'm
gonna be productive today you don't say
I'm going to wake up today and be simple
so woke up today and be productive but I
think you can boil it down to
productivity is how much time do you
think you spend doing useful work versus
a whole day lost in the code I can't
can't understand what's happening or
spending all your day i groom it's
fighting with CI or something like that
so fundamentally go programmers should
feel they can get a lot done and go
that's what I mean by productivity
that's one of the explicit design goals
of the language that when you're working
in a team with other engineers it
doesn't feel like you're working up here
like the language should work with you
in that team environment and there are
plenty of cases where other languages
don't don't work well you know in a
shared environment um I'm not gonna pick
on any contemporary languages but small
talk was an amazing example of this it
was amazingly it was an amazingly
beautiful language but it didn't use
source code it had this binary object
model of the world you didn't save your
program you see realized the whole
memory out to disk
how can you collaborate like that how
can you share a death of my binary state
versus yours so your productivity in
that environment would be drastically
left you can't share Cobo are people you
have to describe how you change the
thing and they apply that transformation
to their model
and there's a joke that that goal was to
sign waiting for a C++ program to
compile this isn't that this this isn't
just hearsay there is from Rob's talk I
think was called more as X less is
exponentially more he talked about going
to see a they spent a lot saw a
lunchtime lecture about new things
happening in C++ they went back to his
office made one tiny change to the code
he was working on pressed pressed enter
to compile and that was 45 minutes he
would have to wait he said he turned
around in his chair to his office mate
who was Ken Thompson and said I can't do
this anymore like we have to we have to
rethink the this was one of the geniuses
of of go
so compilation speed is one of the ways
that we feel we feel productive it's a
concrete example of that well some of
the earliest things written about go say
they want to give you the safety and
concurrency of a static language but
with the product productivity of a
dynamic language they think of Google
back 10 years ago Python Python was the
what was one of the three languages and
so they were directly competing for the
mind share of Python programmers who are
used to working in a ripple
and in turn in terms of the last kind of
founding document there is the splash
document from 2012 which is explicitly
titled software development in the large
it's what Rob and Russ talk about when
they say the language has got a scale
this is industrial scale programming
this is kind of if you stretch the
analogy of manufacturing to some degree
manufacturing works when you have when
you have many actors working at once
together
so these are these are the guiding
principles that that guide what I
describe in this document I really like
the way that the Robert Martin described
principles so like if you think about
like how do you raise you how do you
raise your children you say always tell
the truth don't steal don't lie but when
you when you as you go through your life
and a friend to you says does this you
know do these these pants make me look
fat do you tell the truth maybe maybe
you choose for for the sake of harmony
you say yeah they look great they're
their principles their guidelines
sometimes you bend them sometimes you
don't follow them you do it with the
explicit understanding that there's a
reason that there's a reason is there's
a trade-off but always when faced with
the choice you start with your core
principles
okay
so the first topic I wanted to discuss
is identifies identifier is just a fancy
word for a name the name of a function
never method never package never type no
of anything the odd thing is that given
the quite limited syntax of go the names
we choose for the things in our program
because we have so little flexibility
every else the names have an oversized
impact readability is one of the
defining qualities of good code choosing
good names is crucial to being able to
read the code a concrete example this
when we rewrote the compiler from C to
go the original C compiler was what
people used to call ken CC because none
of the identifiers Zoar longer than five
letters the reason for that was because
that's how they used to do it on the
pdp-11 back in the 60s
your car Smith made this interesting
observation like obvious code is
important like what you can do in one
line should be in three like we don't
optimize for clever one-liners and go
like I know in Python you might have
list comprehensions and in in in ruby
it's it's a real art to like map fold
reduce and little block on the end
that's considered not just to be clever
Ruby but good
idiomatic Ruby style go is not like that
we optimized not for the size on disk or
how many lines we use on the page but
for the reader always for the reader
and key to this clarity is choosing good
names so some of some of the qualities
that define a good name over a bad name
like is again going back to we need to
have a framework to say this is good
therefore that is bad a good name is
concise like like it it needn't be it
needn't be the shortest name but the
good name should waste no space on
things which are extraneous we don't in
go put eyes in front of types that are
interfaces why it's not necessary a good
name is descriptive it should describe
how the variable or a constant is being
used for example it shouldn't describe
what's their contents a good name should
describe the result of a function or a
behavior of a method not how it does
that thing should describe what it's
going to do for you not how it's going
to do for you a good name should
describe the purpose of a package it
shouldn't describe what's inside it and
the better the better the choice of a
name the more accurately describes the
thing it identifies
and also a good name should be
predictable when you see a name a name
in a common a common word that you
understand it should it should spark an
understanding of what that thing is for
a little bit later I show an example if
you find a variable called dB
I think everyone here would argue well
that's probably something to do with the
database it's it's not it's not just
it's not just that database starts with
the DB it's that that's what we've grown
as a tradition that DB means database so
when you see a DB you expect you're
talking about a database
sometimes people criticize go style for
short variable names very much this
grows from some of the original like the
original go code which people call Pike
style because that was the name of a
document that came out I think 1996
which was that it was called Pike style
or PDF the the the the real title of it
was some some notes some notes on
program design in C so this was this was
Rob Rob Pike's
very condensed version of this document
and so given that Rob was one of the
three authors of go then the kind of
predominant naming style that comes out
of go is influenced by that but there
are there are some it's not simply we're
just going to do what Rob says there are
some well thought out guidelines behind
this short variable names work well when
the distance between the Declaration and
the last time they used is short the
longer a variable name is it needs to
pay it needs to pay for that just it
needs to justify that lengthy
bureaucratic names just simply just used
everywhere AB actually obscure what
they're doing like they're you spend
more time reading the name than reading
the code that operates on the name
similarly we we don't tend and go to
include the name of the type in the name
of your variable we don't need to we
have a compiler for that it'll spot
it'll spot it when you get wrong
so let's actually look at an example of
that make that teeny bit smaller so
here's a it is an example probably
written in close to idiomatic go style I
think
idiomatic go star is kind of something
you cannot you can argue about but let's
we have a mix of a mix of identifiers
lengths for example this P here it's
declared on this line and it's only used
once more on the next line over P is
only declared inside the scope of that
for loop it doesn't live for very long
and it's only used as the the loop
induction variable just for adding up
the sum so doesn't live for very long so
we shouldn't spend a lot of time naming
it and care and caring about it because
the arena doesn't need to read it for
very long we have other ones like people
the parameter or count which live for a
longer time like physically on the page
so we give them we give them longer
longer names
now I could have chosen s for some and C
or possibly n for count but that would
have meant that all of the variables in
this function were single letters and so
the opportunity to say which are the
more important ones or ones that live
for longer has been lost
also by choosing P for people I'd need
to think up another thing for the the
range induction variable and just as a
just as a note this is something to
Kevin Kevin Hanny talks out talks about
consider using white space in the same
way that you use what you'd use white
space in a document you break up you
break up paragraphs with with some white
space between it so in this function the
different parts of the functionality
first of all the check of the length and
then the loop and then the returning the
value we kind of separate them that
maybe you agree with you agree with that
maybe you don't but I really like this
this notion of if a function does
several things just in the same way that
a document has a paragraph with several
different ideas or several different sub
points you break them up with white
space
and to go back to talking about
Guidelines versus rules it's important
to recognize that all of this is
contextual
if I if I had applied my my earlier
recommendation here we'd have if that
body of the index was quite long we'd
say four index colon equals zero index
less than the length index plus plus but
is that fundamentally more readable than
this because all eyes do is count is
counting the loop induction it's not
it's it's just it's just a number the
only place it's mutated is right there
on that line otherwise it's just used as
a counter or is some reference so making
it longer doesn't necessarily introduce
the in increase the comprehension of the
function and again there are they're
always counter arguments to this which
of these is more readable we have have a
function with oh I D and index now if it
was a very like fetch you might think it
was a getter or something like that if
we shortened oh I D to just oh it means
that programmers have to translate in
SNMP oh I D is called object ID it's
already a contraction and it's the name
that everybody talks about the
identifiers in SNMP so by introducing by
calling it oh now everyone who in all
the documentation all the RS sees about
SNMP and all the other libraries and
everything you google about they they
know it is OID now all of a sudden they
have to translate in their head o means
oh i do means OID and the reason the
reason that we call it index not I is
don't mix and match long and short long
and short parameter names again for
readability like don't if one is very if
if one is spelled in full make the
others as well similarly if you're going
for short variable names and make them
more short
naming naming you variables like giving
them a suffix with their type um is the
same reason you don't name pets dog and
cat like my dog's name is called Frank
it's not Frank dog it's very very
obvious she's a dog so that the name of
your variable should describe its
contents can consider not the type of
their contents to consider the example
I'm sure I'm sure you've probably seen
code like this in in various places
users map is a map of string to user
what's good about the declaration we can
see it's a map obviously I mean we don't
need to we don't need to say map right
here it says map literally one character
to the left
but more importantly users map is a map
because we have a statically typed
language and so you're not going to
accidentally use it where you're
expecting something else the compiler is
going to stop you accidentally using a
map like in in other languages where
there's a lot of dynamic coercion like
Ruby JavaScript things like that you
probably you it may be good practice to
encode the way you're supposed to access
this variable actually in its name
because if you don't the language will
try and transform it into the way that
you the way that you tried to access it
and maybe that'll be wrong but to make
this argument a bit a bit further
consider what happens if we were to
declare some other variables like we
have some users we get some companies we
have some products you think in some
kind of sales system or HR system and so
now we have users map company's map
product map we know their Maps it's
right there in the definition we also
know that their declaration prevents us
from transposing them you can't put a
company into a product it's just not
going to work
now if you remove the suffix I I argue
to you that that made it clearer
like the map was adding nothing I mean
as I say here if users isn't descriptive
enough and calling it users map it's
probably not going to solve whatever
problem there was I'm an interest
interestingly consider the case of users
map versus user map depending on the
local pilots that you may remove the
plural like but if we then remove the
word map which the reader is going to do
because they just transport like they're
like y'all know it's map I'm just going
to ignore that bit one is a map of users
so clearly it's going to be users users
key to users another one just becomes
user so is that properties about a user
or is it properties about a map of users
it's not clear from looking at the
variable
this advice also applies to function
parameters for example naming the
parameter config is sort of redundant
because the type is config we know it's
a configured said it just said that
right there so maybe you might call it
conf or see if the life lifetime is very
very short um if there's more than one
config in scope sometimes you start with
them you start with a function and then
you add some more parameters over time
or it grows grow somewhat he will put
more over time like say it was copying
the configuration or mutating the
configuration calling them conf one and
conf two they only differ by one
character at the end consider instead
calling like original and updated that
which describes this was the original I
copied from it updated this is where I
went
and that that there's there's a tip here
which is probably maybe go specific but
important nonetheless which is don't let
package names steal good variable names
when I import when I import the context
package the word context is declared at
the package scope I I cannot to read
eclair it becomes very difficult and
this is why this is why when you see the
context on context duty called CTX
because context the word is already
taken the database SQL package
might be SQL database I think probably
the other way around there is the reason
the reason that was called SQL database
slash SQL not the other way around is
you would be importing the database
package which means you could not have a
variable called database that was one of
there was one of the main reasons for
switching switching those around
and as I said a good name should be
predictable the reader should be able to
understand the use of the name the first
time they encounter it like your names
should be should be descriptive and when
they encounter a common name they should
be able to assume that well this is
probably not changed its meaning since
the last time I saw it so a good name
should be familiar when you see dB
you know you're talking about a database
when you see SQL or trans you you're txn
you know you're talking about some kind
of transaction so be consistent in the
names that used to describe things
because that consistency builds
familiarity so rather than like D
sometimes and D base and capital D be
sometimes in database just be consistent
always use DB whether it's in parameter
return value a local Declaration even
potentially the receiver
and there is there is there is attention
here they can the convention for short
receiver names this is a is you know
normally we call a receiver a single
letter or at most one or two letters
taken from from the type this is this is
a case of just the local star the local
idiom just like the use of camel case
which use camel case rather than snake
case it's just how we do it and go and
it's also important to remember that
outside of going the wider world of
programming there are some variables
which have traditional name which which
have traditional uses I J and K come
from Fortran in Fortran the letters I
let variable starting with the letters A
through n the first two characters in
the word integer were integers
everything was just everything else was
a float so they usually use for simple
loops v v is shown is common shorthand
for a value when you have a generic kind
of function okay for key a and B or a
usually used for generic generic names
for two things that you're going to
compare when you have a max function
you'll always pass in an a or and a B so
again this is this is the local style
this helps not just local style but the
general style this helps programmers
become familiar and easier to read your
code because they're not cut they're not
constantly asking wall is I being used
for a loop or is I being used for
something else
it just helps familiarity
so go has at least six different ways to
declare a variable now that doesn't
include the receiver it doesn't include
the parameters has include name return
variables and they're probably some
elders that I haven't thought of in fact
one that it's not a variable but imports
is another another way that you can
declare and identify this is definitely
something that goes to signers
recognized was probably a mistake but
it's too late to change it now and they
argue probably correctly in fact I agree
with them that the bigger problem is
shadowing like getting like a holy war
about this it's not as important as
detecting shadowing shadowing mistakes
but with all those different
permutations if we were all break to our
own corners and randomly choose our own
our own our own rules that reduces
readability because again it's not
familiar
so I want to present to you the the the
kind of guideline that I follow I'll try
and justify to you maybe it maybe you'll
find it useful
so that the fundamental underlying thing
here is that Ingo each variable has a
purpose it has to because they have to
be used within the scope they will
declared you can't declare it way up
there and not use it and declaring
something at a global and then using it
at local is also very very difficult so
when you see a variable your first
question is what does it do what is it
here for and so that's the question we
should answer for the reader so this is
the style I use so when declaring but
not initializing so use var so that is
we're letting the value have its default
0 value so here players is 0 VAR things
which is a slice of things as an empty
slices are nil slice and thing is an
empty is an empty thing variable not a
pointer to an empty thing value not a
pointer to a value
now the opposite is when you're
declaring and initializing so you're
declaring it and giving it an initial
value the style I use is the colony call
style and this is because we want to
make it explicit to the reader that we
are not choosing the zero value
I declare I declared this variable
because I intend to give it this value
so to try and justify this this position
let's take the original and this time
we're going to deliberately initialize
each variable so players in equals zero
things is nil and var thing is a new
thing now immediately after we do this
the the way that the way that the go
syntax works and that the fact that
there are no automatic conversions only
type inference the type on the left hand
side can be inferred from the right hand
side so immediately we can simplify that
just down to this like players wasn't
int the default the the default for a
numeric type is an int
and so this leaves leaves us with the
explicitly initializing players to zero
which is redundant because zero is the
type zero value so it's better to be
clear that we're choosing explicitly to
be zero rather than why are they setting
the thing to zero when it's already zero
so what about the second syntax we can't
alight the type we can't write via
things equals nil this is because nil in
this context does not have a type
instead we have to choose what we want
the zero value for this slice to be do
we want it to be the zero value for a
slice which is a nil or do we want to
create a slice with zero elements if we
wanted the latter that is not the zero
value for a slice the zero vote for a
slice is nil this is actually explicitly
initializing the slice to point to an
array with no elements so given that we
want to make it clear to the reader that
we deliberately did this want to say to
the reader yes I actually wanted a thing
with no elements so the style that I
follow we make it clear by using colon
equals it says we deliberately chose to
do this
and so that brings us to the third
declaration of our thing equals new
thing which is both explicit
initializing the variable and uses the
uncommon use of new now some go
programmers dislike new they get very
upset there is a low duplication between
new and taking the address of a compact
literal I get very upset there is there
appear to be two ways to do the same
thing
however there is there is a difference
this is declaring a new thing and
letting all the pram all the values
inside thing be there there's zero value
which itself is the zero value for a
thing so we're making a new thing
explicitly asking for its default values
and then taking a pointer to it that's a
lot to say that that that's a lot of
that's a lot of conceptual overhead to
say just give me just give me the thing
in front of me what we're actually
saying is this declare anything and pass
its address to unmarshal so even though
it took two lines this is much much
clearer at the intent
now as with all guidelines there are
always always places where if you
followed the rules like a stickler you
would make the readability worse you
like you you you you you teach your
children follow the laws don't speed but
if someone's having a baby in a hospital
you drive real fast so there are cases
where where sometimes with justification
you bend the rules and an example of
this is if we followed the style that I
just dictated you would end up with
something like this VAR min int because
we want the minimum to be zero and want
the maximum to be a thousand but it
looks super weird like we have two
variables which are closely related
minimum maximum declared in different
styles one of them has it one of has
Phenix kind of falls to the zero value
the other to explicitly declared so I
think we can argue that this is much
much clearer what I intended
and the other one is that this this is
like that comes up I think Brian
Kernighan writes this frequently which
is make when something is being
complicated when something is tricky
make it obvious that it's tricky like
very rarely do you need to use unsigned
types especially the correct sized
unsigned type but when you're dealing
with Network Star for sis calls they
have very strong alignment requirements
and so this break breaks the rule that
they're all this time giving it a an
actual vote value then I should use the
colon equal syntax but if we look at the
colon int a equal syntax version of it
length equals colon equals you int 32 of
some number
so could be could be asked equally an
assumed why is that why is that constant
being cast to un 32 like what's what so
what's so special about that the the the
prior syntax says that we're explicitly
declaring length to be of this type
whereas someone down here could be like
well I don't understand why this is un
32 and just remove that cast so again
it's just sometimes break the rules and
cinematographers do this all the time
break the rules when they want to draw
your attention to something because it
looks unusual I mean in horror movies
they generally will remove frames of
movement so that the the spooky
character or the evil character will
move unnaturally because the human
reptilian brain is hardwired that things
which moves smoothly are probably part
of your your flock or your pack or your
your herd things which move erratically
could be a predator so cinematographers
break the rules by making the character
move unnaturally to draw your attention
to it and actually make you afraid so
make tricky things stand out
and lastly in this in this section um
software engineering is team sport
you're most you're most likely to spend
most of your career working on software
which you're not the sole author you're
going to have to collaborate on other
people and they they are going to come
in and cooperate on your projects so if
you come into a project and the local
style is somehow not how you like it and
we're much luckier in an NGO than in
other languages because of the absolute
dominance of go forms there is no the
rejection of go format is awesome almost
reject programming and go so we're very
very lucky that even if you do find some
source code which is unformatted almost
by the time you open it in your editor
some tool is reformatted for you but
even still there are there may be
differences in styles in the naming of
variables and my advice my advice there
is the uniformity even if it may not be
the preferred style you have is more
important than the code that you added
has one style the code somebody else has
another style that detracts from the
readability because it is jarring to
constantly flip between these so if
you're not that if you're not the first
one to touch the file follow follow the
footsteps of the person who did and of
course lastly if you just cannot stand
it at all and you must do a mass
reformatting you've a code base
please don't smuggle those in with other
changes ie it is the worst to do a git
bisect of a 5,000 line diff just because
someone changed whitespace shape don't
mix your formatting changes with actual
functional changes
okay um
I'm kind of on a roll but I do want to
want to make this this interactive if
they if you have questions please put up
your hand if you have if you want to
refute anything I'm saying please please
I really want your feedback we might do
one more one more section and we'll see
how we're going for time I love this
quote from from Dave Thomas good code
has lots of comments bad code requires
lots of comments
Dave Dave Thomas gave a presentation
last year at Yau where he talked about
his his wave for writing code and the
first thing he does is writes the
comment of the function and that's good
style you should I mean if you like then
your function has has a comment already
before you started writing it but the
reason he does that is he's writing
himself a map for what he's going to do
and it's not simply that you think about
what you're going to write before you
think about the code you're going to
write he looks out for kitten for
conjunctions like and and comma and so
he writes a function that says the
such-and-such will connect to the
database comma and update the update the
user record he sees that as a red flag
because now he knows that function is
doing two things so wait so he uses that
as a as a clue to himself that this
function does two things well I should
actually be writing these two functions
one that one that gets the record and
the second one that is past the record
and does some changing a bit state then
maybe you go back and you you write the
first function because at some point
somebody has to join that business logic
together but it's better that they are
independent actions joint joined
together rather than multiple different
multiple different pieces of
functionality in one function so
comments a comments are can be used as a
really powerful powerful tool
but argue to you that um they're
actually different styles of comments
there do they do different things the
threat the three that I can think of our
comment that explains what the thing
does that's that's your commentary on
public symbols yeah you said what this
function does that you go dog that your
method documentation the second second
one is explain how something does and
that this the formatting is messed up
there I'll fix that in a second but the
comments should explain how the thing
does what it does now you don't want
expose that to the user that's not part
of your documentation you because you
shouldn't document the implementation
you should document the behavior but
inside you if it's a complicated method
you may have some exemplary text that
says this this is what we're going to do
we have to do these things in this order
because of another another condition and
the last one the comment to explain why
a thing is it is I think is the most
important part of part of a comment
now it doesn't displace go dog
documentation it doesn't displace some
internal notes about how the function
does what it does but this is it comes
down to documenting the the business
rules that led to this code and that
these are usually non code factors this
comes from a piece of code inside inside
my product where we discovered that by
default envoy if you don't supply this
you have to wait for 50% of the back
ends to report a failure before they
report a failure it's the most default
behavior so of course we have to change
this default way but we have to
explicitly set the healthy panic
threshold and so this this comment does
two things it gives a clue to the reader
why why is this like why am I like
surely zero should be the default we
have to explain to the reader that no no
no but if I what it chooses something
very bizarre and all
so we give a clue to where you can go
and find out more CS
links to issues design documents are SES
it's it's not the place to write the
entire history of the issue here but you
want to give enough of a crib note that
somebody else can find and follow the
breadcrumbs github issues are perfectly
the amount of the amount of code that
you know has in comment you know see
issues editor for workaround
comments on variables and constants
should describe their contents not their
purpose
it's a little contradictory there yes
should describe the variables contents
not its purpose I need to improve the
wording there so for example random
number equals six if anybody if anybody
remembers the xkcd joke determined from
role of an unbiased eye it doesn't we
don't describe here y rat we describe
why round a number is given six we don't
say what it's for
we don't say how it's going to be used
and this is deliberate this is a public
symbol random number it can be
referenced by many many packages
packages we don't know packages that
haven't been written yet so how can we
possibly document how somebody else is
going to use this number instead we
explain the name of the constant should
be a guide for for potential users like
you're unlikely to use a variable called
random number when you actually wanted a
fixed number or a specific value like
it's kind of the clue is right there in
its name
this is also important for bringing in
semantic context from that is bigger
than is bigger than your program so for
example 100 is just a number you can
count from 1 to 100
but in the context of HTTP when two
things that are talking HTTP talk say
the number 100 to each other they mean
status continue so give a clue to the
reader where you where where you decided
that 100 means status continue by you
know referencing the referencing the
spec or the RFC
that gives a person the clue of why this
is a hundred and if perhaps they get a
bug that thinks maybe there's a mistake
in that table they can go to the the RFC
and say oh I did transpose that wrong
so for a variable without an initial
value the comet should describe who's
responsible for it this is pretty much
the this is getting really into terrible
design smell territory we have a
variable deep in the bowels of the go
compiler called size calculation
disabled it's a it's a global variable
and there is a comment which
unfortunately has been cut off I'll fix
that that describes that there's another
function called do width actually just
find that
so the act the actual comment in the the
code says indicates whether it's safe to
do a certain thing and it's II do width
says do width is responsible for this
this variable let me show you something
cool
fixed
so
when you when you see this like the
there already enough design smells in
here that you should be feeling quite
nervous here like like why why is it is
a function responsible for maintaining
the a global state like shouldn't they
they're intimately entwined like the
only person who should be touching this
is his function called do width so the
only person who should be able to touch
it we should put them into an object or
something like that is a really big big
clue when you need to write a comment
like this that you have an underlying
design problem Kate Gregory has this
fantastic observation that sometimes
dang it
I know exactly let's go
sometimes the better name for your
variable is actually hiding right in
that comment like someone called it
registry is it a bridal registry is the
registry of Motor Vehicles no it's a
registry of SQL drivers if you just call
it SQL drivers then it's very clear what
it what it contains and also you don't
need to comment anymore what's in here
there are skilled drivers
um hopefully this goes without saying
you should always document your public
symbols um you should put a comment on
everything that is a public variable
constant function methods all those
things this come this recommendation
comes from the Google style guide that's
not it I think this is actually there
Bosch style guide but they have to have
two rules any public function which is
not both obvious and short so possibly
the only thing that would fit into that
would be something like Mac's
like a3 if it's longer than three lines
you probably need to give a comment on
it and any function in a library must be
must must be commented regardless of
length or complexity so that basically
saying if your code is going to be used
by somebody else you need to put a
comment on it and that's just that's
just good style
let me just quickly check it's because
ask you doc into the slash slash to be
the there we go consider slash slash to
be the comment whether it's inside a
code block or not there we go now there
is one exception to this rule you don't
I argue that you don't need to document
methods that implement an interface
specifically don't do this
read implements the reader interface
that says nothing the only thing that
can happen to that comment is you can
get out of date
I want to show you how the how the IO
package deals with this so we have a
limit reader which is a reader the limit
reader function is a constructor limited
reader reads from that other returns it
describes all the behavior of a reading
type thing and immediately following it
here's a type called read we know it's a
reader we set it about eight times just
before you hit that what interface this
is implement probably reader it's a
little bit contextual and it is it is
slightly odd that limited reader is a
public type I think if this was this
class was being this packages being
designed today that would given that you
have a constructor for it that would
probably not be exported which again
means that this function without a
comment is not going to show up in go
doc but the the the takeaway is don't
don't take this the the stipulation that
you must comment everything that is
public because it just leads you into
doing things like this which add no
value
um Brian Kearney don't comment bad code
just rewrite it and I have some some
comments written out of frustration in
in in my product there's one
particularly dealing with glog glog must
be initialized in a particular way and I
when someone fixed-fixed this I demanded
the PR include a very salty comment just
how upset I was that we had to do this
rubbish but that the more grown-up way
is if you encounter like a comment that
says this is broken we should do a
better way you need like it's not
sufficient that it's just there in the
code you need to take action to register
that technical debt and make a plan to
fix it in go that the the predominant
style is to do style like you know for
coming from Python it's xxx I don't know
Ruby style is I think Java has a
annotation but only on Java dokoni on
the the method but the the the
predominant style we do here is the word
to do and actually there are tools that
look for that the putting you username
or some identifier like who you are in
the brackets he's not saying I'm going
to fix this it is when somebody else
comes across it say they want to know
more context like like what were you
thinking that you didn't have time to do
well I can ask Dave about that this is
an OK comment a better one is to say we
should fix this and a link to the issue
so you can say because comments get out
of date if you link to an issue and you
go to get up and find that that issues
been closed you can you can delete that
comment so don't it's not simply enough
just to like right out of frustration
this could be better we could do better
link it to some actual some actual way
of improving so to do's and pointing to
issues are a great way of doing it
and the last one to close on is this
observation that do you need do you need
to comment everything like like comments
that just describe exactly what's going
to happen next add no value more
importantly can you write that this
probably describes for the second class
of commentary the one inside that
describes how a method does what it does
if you can improve the code through
break extracting the method for giving
them better names maybe you you can you
can remove the textual description of
what it does which has to been which has
to be in sync with the code that it's
describing if you can make the code self
describing then removing the comment is
even better and of course one of the
best ways to do that is extract method
we're doing on time
any questions
does anything anybody wants to hear many
disagree with or agree with um
yeah oh we had to okay you were first
cuz I looking at you then I'll come to
you yes it's alright the last thing
anyone about it okay so the question is
the name you can sometimes be hard
especially when you're exploring with
code
you might you may disagree with this but
the way that I think about software
development is that what happens on my
machine you know like is you know like
that's very you know what happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas what happens on my
machine before I push a PR it stays on
my machine I jet Jim generally I you
know when I push a branch I'm looking at
like look let's look at the diff can i
improve the diff so I don't focus I
don't focus when I'm writing the code
what I focus on is getting the tests at
that point but when it comes to actually
pushing the change to pushing a change
to github that's when I look and say can
I make this smaller can I make this
cleaner is there any is there any is
there any duplication that I can remove
from there and you may you may want to
want one of the other ways when I mean
I'm running a big feature is it I'll
just write whatever it takes to get it
done and then that's in a branch and
then I start to peel off [ __ ] it bits
of those branches and clean them up as I
go along too so I don't work in an
incremental fashion I get the thing
working
but then as I'm trying to feed it into
the codebase I peel off bits and that's
probably the case where I'll say is this
name descriptive because your instead of
a 500 line if you're working with little
units of 60 or 70 and that that's more
tractable and more incremental yes
yes
extract in essence and
so the the the the the question is
simplicity is subjective yeah and that
that is that is the the big fundamental
underlying problem of all of this like
Wiggly there is no I mean rich Hickey
has a very he goes back to the
dictionary and this but to define
simplicity from its root which is
simplex which is one singular whereas
complex comes from complex which means
to bind and and interweave so you you
can approach you from that point of view
like that that's that's why ideas like
extract method mean you do once that you
do one thing and you do another thing
and then the one thing is to combine the
two of those but you you're right that
taken to the taken to the extreme you
have methods two to one the two what
methods was very descriptive name the
two very little like the code becomes
overwhelming its
my my answer to you is that this is an
agreement but between your team like if
somebody says that is too complex I
can't understand it they're part of the
group as well if you you have to reach
reach and equal an equilibrium one way
for to one way for dealing with that is
that the idea of hiding complexity
okay this algorithm is very complex then
we're going to put it in its own package
with its own set of tests and with its
own API and then for everybody else who
needs to interact with it rather than
maintain it their their interactions
with it are much much simpler so those
are some suggestions but I do agree that
fundamentally there apart from a
dictionary definition of simplicity
which is hard to which is hard to
internalize this is a process of all
this this is what this this workshop is
it's me sharing with you my experiences
and the way that I try and think about
this problem yeah go for a bill where
one is absolutely precise
all right no reason to find a function
that isn't precise about the behavior
it's close to exhibit now you're right
in generic culture very abstractions
should define a new semantic behavior
that is precise put that in your head
morning for the recording so your ear
what I just said right every abstraction
every function should define a new
semantic or behavior that is precise
it's obvious on what it's providing now
readability for me means not hiding the
cost of what that code is doing you
should be able to look at every line of
code and understand the cost of that
alright and I'm not talking performance
cost so much what we understand what
it's going to do I also understand the
behavior we're not hiding anything this
is why when Dave says well simplicity is
fighting readability because simplicity
is about hiding complexity so you're not
allowed to hide complexity if you lose
readability you're not allowed to have
it
and that's a subjective again for your
team right the average developer on your
team should be able to understand the
entire code base you're working on and
all of the mental models around it so
for me it's subjective to the team but
if I see somebody writing a function
that is not precise or in what it does
red flag if their answer was well I did
that because I wanted to abstract seven
lines of boilerplate code that I have to
keep copying and pasting I see but you
haven't defined really a new semantics
here we're now losing readability
because I could have just put the seven
lines of code everywhere it was and I
fully understand when I get to that
piece of the code what it means but no
now you've abstracted it around
something because you didn't want to
copy and paste it seven times
so for me you write a piece of code you
get it working you do a readability
review of that code immediately are we
following our design philosophies are is
everything in line for where we are
right now on readability not hiding cost
is everybody on the team understand this
simplicity which to me is you have to
discover simplicity by the way can't
design for it you discover it once
you've got working code
it was brilliant around simplicity it
abstracts garbage college it abstracts
all the machine from you but you can
look at any line of code and know what's
gonna have a cake right you don't have
to but you can scheduling is completely
you know hidden from you right but but
it's not really in terms of cost go can
do this over and over and over again
it's amazing but it's discovered it's
not designed so those are my thoughts on
that
thank you um so okay what looking at the
time what we might do is do one more
section then we'll take a take a break
come back
so I've kind of been working from the
small up to the larger and so now now
we've had names comments functions now
we're kind of it package design because
it's fundamentally I think I think of
the package as the unit of deliverable
in go not not anything else um in his in
his book test-driven design camp back
describes this idea of a unit of
software and the unit in almost a
physics term is is indivisible it's the
it's it's the smallest amount that you
can observe so for a long for a long
time for a long time in in physics we
didn't even know about the subatomic
particles I mean we we now know that
atoms are composed of quarks and bosons
and fermions and other things like that
but we can't observe them directly I
thought the way the way that they
observed these were shooting beams of
beams of electrons through an atom and
inferring from the way that the
electrons were scattered what was
happening you can't observe them
directly you can just infer
so if a unit is in software is composed
of smaller so-called subatomic particles
as the color of the software somewhere
from outside that package we can't
directly observe them or I'm going to
make that stronger and say we should not
be able to directly observe them because
fundamentally what we're observing would
be implementation details instead what
we want is to rely only on the behavior
of that unit now the size of the unit of
software differs differs by language in
C the unit is probably the function
because in C you don't actually have
anything but functions you have macros
which are just text editing in Java the
unit of common software is commonly miss
believed to be the class there's a great
there's a great talk by Ian Cooper who
it's called TDD where where did it all
go wrong and it talks about how in the
Java world the predominant style has
been one test class what one class on
test class but in go the unit of
software I argue to you isn't the
function or the method or the type it's
the package because looking from outside
as an observer of the package someone
observing it through its behavior we
can't see into the package we can only
see the public API
the public API package describes what it
does not how it does it a well-designed
package should do that and equally your
public API should try not to leak
implementation details either by types
or via some kind of observable behavior
of like the ordering of things or any or
any of those things so I'm going to talk
in the section more about how to have to
do these things like how do how to
create what I think is a good package
and fundamentally the goal of a package
is to provide a set of behaviors right a
good package like fundamentally starts
with this name a kind of common retort
that I like to use to people is to say
that the name of your package is your
kind of one word elevator pitch is that
story that you get in an elevator you
have to you have 12 seconds to pitch a
prominent Silicon Valley venture
capitalist he's right next to you in the
elevator when the doors open they get to
their floor you missed you missed your
boat in this sentence you have one word
to describe what your package is going
to do for them to sell it
and fundamentally if you're one if you
choose your one word to be utils or
common or base kind of blown it so just
like I talked about the naming of
variables the naming of packages are
very important the name should should
say what is the purpose of this package
what services will I get when I use this
package what is it going to do for me
the name shouldn't describe how it's
going to do that and it certainly
shouldn't describe what is inside the
package that's useless um in such a
project each package should be unique
they say should I mean there's no must
in any of this but they they should be
unique because you shouldn't have two
packages providing the same thing like
if your package name is descriptive or
what it provides then you shouldn't have
that functionality sprayed across
multiple packages and if you find you
have two packages with the same name
it's likely either that the package name
is too deep too generic and not
descriptive client worker shared I mean
they are names but they like if there's
a client there's probably a server
package right next to it if there's a
worker that's probably a manager
somewhere if they're shared there's
probably also a private so a name which
needs a twin or needs it needs a partner
is not a descriptive name
now if you find a package overlaps with
another if you can consider merging them
or in cases where like these are
utilities or things like that that don't
belong in this give them a more
descriptive name and the two examples I
point to IO / io you tilt and HTTP HTTP
you tell which are groupings of
utilities if if we were to design them
again perhaps they wouldn't be in the
standard library but the key is that
it's not I Oh slash util because that
would make the name of the package util
which is neither descriptive nor unique
because that would also mean we have a
net slash HTTP slash util so sticking
the boot into utility packages um these
are where kind of utility your helper
code just kind of congeals over time and
because these packages are assortment
you know got a mixed assortment of
unrelated functions the utility is hard
to describe in terms of what it provides
think about when you go to the
supermarket and you buy I can go to the
supermarket and buy a bag of mixed
lollies it's because it doesn't provide
or contain only jelly babies or any of
those little kind of strawberry cream
things it contains a mixture so it's
name is mixed lollies that's all you can
say about it and packages in my
experience like the utils and the helper
packages tend to grow inside large
projects when people overuse overuse
other packages and they generally those
packages the utils and the Commons and
the sheds and the bases grow because
somebody's had to break an import loop
by moving some of that code outside
because the name of the package
is derived from its you its function its
function is to break this import loop it
doesn't have a really good name because
its name is not not driven by what it
provides it's driven simply by the need
to break this import loop
um my my recommendation in try very hard
to not have utility packages and
certainly try not to have a utility
library that is the worst or get into
exactly why that is in a second because
fundamentally as a little duplication
like having the same helper function a
few times he's fine it's private I mean
if you if you move it out of a utility
function into the place that it's called
it no longer needs to be exported and if
it's not exported it's not part of your
public API you have a lot more
flexibility to change it to remove it to
refactor it when it's not part of
actually the code that you're committing
to support using plurals is good for
naming naming you to utility packages I
mean there are examples in the standard
library like the strings package that
provides everything you need to know
about strings it's not called string
it's called strings
now to give some examples of this in
I'll take Java because I have a good
background in that because of Java's are
elaborate package hierarchy in fact you
can have many different access modifiers
it is very common that you'll have a
package for the client package for the
server and a package called common which
is the common bits in between it in go
let's take our HTTP package we have a
file called client we have a file called
server and the common types between them
go into an idea called transport which
is the the RSC message transport in both
directions it's important to remember
again thinking from the consumer of your
package that the name of your package in
sorry the name of your your symbol like
your function or your type includes the
name of the package so what you think is
get inside you're working in your HTTP
library everybody else knows as HTTP GET
it's pretty descriptive strings dot
reader is strings dot reader and the
error interface type to define in the
net package when other people refer to
it is net dot error so you have that
facility that if you give your package a
good name it amplifies the names of the
types inside it there are certainly
examples of getting this wrong in the
standard library hash dot hash is
terrible it's terrible I like that that
says nothing but it says it twice but we
have we have much much more powerful
examples which is IO dot reader which
has become fundamental to the way that
people think about IO and go
now because we don't have exceptions for
control flow and go there's no
requirement to put the successful code
inside indented inside the try block
instead the predominant style and go is
guard clauses a bunch of preconditions
and early returns from them which means
as you go down the function you know
that successfully more and more checks
have been passed this also means that
the success case lives on the lives on
the left-hand side of the code it
doesn't disappear up into the right so
Matt Matt Raya talks a lot about this he
calls it line of sight coding the idea
is that it doesn't disappear off out of
sight from the screen
so to give an example give an example of
this this is I just picked this from
that from the bytes package because it
kind of proves proves my point which
uses the kind of guard clause style we
have a check at the top then we do we do
some behavior here I think there might
be a little bit missing from there and
then we have the we have the return
behavior so we know that
this can work probably we know once we
get to this point here that last read is
greater than that greater than up
invalid so we know that precondition
holds for the rest of the function let's
have a look if I rewrote it in a kind of
where the success case is nested inside
first of all we have to turn up invalid
to turn the ignition around and then now
it's not clear to the reader
there are now two returns there's one
here there's one down here so we need to
read the entire body of the function to
know are we going to exit from here or
are we going to exit from here also you
can imagine that this was a more
complicated function the risk of this
logic nesting inside itself rolling off
to the right is much bigger the thing is
that as I said to figure out which
return case you have to count the braces
this is I think one of the fundamental
reasons why we prefer the go core style
another one this is this I think this is
almost a proverb make the 0 value useful
because every value that's declared if
you don't initialize it you get the zero
value and this is important not just for
safety and correctness we don't have
uninitialized memory and go but
importantly if go program is internalize
this facility it can make the code a lot
e you can make the code a lot easier to
write and therefore a lot easier to read
now an example of this sinc doc mutex
contains two unexploited integer fields
they represent the mutex internal state
and thanks to the magic of the zero
value they get given the values zero
when a mutex is declared we don't need a
constructor for that we just arrange the
code such that 0 is the unlocked state
this means any time even embedded or
even as a field inside another type you
can just declare it like that you can
imagine if to use a mutex you had to
call sink new mutex and then assign that
to if imagine this was star sink mutex
that this type
my aunt was not safe unless you've done
that extra value would force two things
on you one you would probably have a
constructor for that and so you have
more constructors and more constructors
you have literally just to initialize
memory the second one is that wherever
you see a my int you don't know if it's
been correctly initialized like if it
gets if a reference that gets passed in
you don't know whether someone knew to
correctly assign a mutex to it and I
picked this example because I do pick
this up a lot in code review then
whenever I see a pointer to a mutex that
is a huge that is a huge red flag it's
not to say it's not it's never it's
never correct but that is a case where
you're sharing a lock between but
between two different variable values
and that I've never seen that
successfully done that is always a
mistake
we do this all the time with bite
stuffer you don't need to call bite
stock new buffer and that you can just
use a bites buffer straightaway it
implements an interface straightaway it
works just as you would you don't need
to explicitly initialize it okay useful
property of slices is again they have
really useful zero value the slice
trucked in the runtime has two fields
length and capacity and the zero value
for those is going to be zero so by
default a slice even if it points no no
matter what memory that's pointing to a
length of zero in a capacity of zero
means that the first thing you do with
it are to append with it is going to
properly initialize it
I should mention that slices have it is
possible to tell the difference between
an empty initialized slice of no
elements and a nil slice reflect D
people equal can spot this but really
you shouldn't structure your code that
it needs to know the difference between
is this string nil or is this string it
is this slice nil or is it have 0 how
have 0 elements you can use the length
property on both of them and if you
build your code around that then it can
be much more flexible with strings with
slices constructed either way
and the opposite is true as well it's a
somewhat surprising property but
initialize pointers you can call methods
on them and so this can be an
interesting way of providing default
values so we have we have a config in
the case c1 is not initializes it points
to nil so we're going to so we can check
for that kneel in there and provide a
default value so you this this is a way
of creating configuration struts that if
values haven't been given to them they
can respond with a with a sensible
default
all right this is the last one that
we'll take we'll take a break
I know buddy's setting up or cleaning up
um and the key to writing maintainable
program maintainable programs and
maintainable packages in this case is
that they should be loosely coupled I
changed to one package should have a low
probability of affecting another there
are two excellent ways of ensuring that
this is true first one is use interfaces
when communicating between packages the
caller should describe the behavior they
should describe the behavior at once but
by using an interface rather than rather
than specific specifying a concrete type
and the other one is avoid global state
in the globe and go we can declare
variables at the block at the function
level method scope we can also do it a
package scope this is what I mean by
global scope because if we make that
variable public then its scope is
effectively global to the entire program
anybody that knows the name of that
variable can change it and they can
observe changes to it and what this
means is that global variables become
invisible parameters to every single
function and method that you write
because the fact the body of that
function method can change its behavior
based on some global state we saw an
example of that do width function
earlier that it's but it's behavior will
change and the rest of the compiler will
change based on that the state of saying
something disabled so
now that's weird enough as it is but
this also has implications for
maintainability any function that relies
in a global bearable will cease to
compile if you change the type of that
variable it's public you don't know
who's depending on it and if you change
the type of it it will it will fail to
compile and of course any function that
relies on the state of that variable can
be broken if another part changes it
incorrectly if you have if you have
functions that are coordinating
themselves through [ __ ] through a shared
global variable it's very hard to
contain that state it's very hard to
know if you've found all the places that
mutate that so if you want to reduce
coupling move your relevant variables
into fields on Struck's as you need them
that also means that instead of having
one of these states in the entire
program it's now encapsulated in you
know in a type in an object and
therefore anyone who previously referred
to the global state just needs a
reference to your instance of it and as
I said use the interfaces to reduce the
coupling between between packages
because interfaces let you talk about
the behavior not how that behavior is
implemented so I think we should take a
break for 15 minutes yeah 15 minutes
we'll get will keep us on time 15 20
minutes and then we'll come back we'll
talk about some more about go
so now that we've talked about a package
singular let's talk about the real the
real name of the game which is combining
packages together into projects either
libraries or your application
I want to point out that I use the word
I use the word project but given with go
one look 13 coming up and the the use of
go modules a module and a project are
pretty interchangeable like a module has
a very specific meaning that is the
thing defined by Godot mod a project is
that the name I give to a git repository
with some go source code in it which is
pretty much how we think of a go project
um the same as a package I argue to you
that each project should have a clear
purpose now if your project is a library
like it should try it's goal should be
to do one thing I say if it's like XML
parsing or logging it shouldn't all like
you're logging library shouldn't also
include an XML parser and your XML
parser shouldn't also include a JSON
parser like you should you should be
clear what your project does by having
giving it a common goal and the reason
that the reason I say this is that I
really want to dissuade you from this
idea of a common library um to to just
check my understanding when I say a
common library I mean you have a project
it's been going on for some time and you
start a second project and then someone
has the idea that oh this this
functionality need to share it between
them and so very quickly you arrive at a
library not which does XML parsing or a
logging library but one that follows the
same idea it's common code we want to
share behind it but the only thing is is
this sharing that the purpose is
ill-defined it's just a bag of helpers
and features have people come across
that in projects they work on
one two come on yeah it's a bit more
like in so for those who haven't I'm
gonna say that you're lucky because I've
also worked on projects like this and
there is not just the kind of common is
a bad name for things the more important
thing is that the common repository its
evolution is tied to which largest
consumer so if you have in my example
with when I worked on juju at canonical
we took most of the things we thought
would be common would be useful that
we'd written in juju and we pulled them
out into a common common library which
meant that they were they were separate
in separate repositories but they live
they were conceptually the same any
change to we needed to juju we had to
change in the common library first and
then we use that functionality there so
that the common library and its biggest
consumer are tied closely and that means
that the smaller consumers get the rough
end of the stick they that they usually
encouraged to put common helper code
into this common library but
fundamentally they may have to wait for
a long time for it Peter upgraded or
worse they may be force upgrade and be
broken because because the big project
pulls them along now and this this also
became much more insidious when it
became backports obviously if you went
to work for canonical we had to maintain
four different releases of every
software one for every that we do the
release every six months so we had at
any one time we had four versions of our
product the one that shipped in the four
different versions of Ubuntu they spent
that we also had to have four different
versions of the combin library obviously
because they're tied together now the
problem the problem there is to backport
a fix to interpret into older versions
of the product that fix usually involves
changing the common library which means
you need to Rev which means you need to
upgrade like you let your land the chick
fix into the common library and you then
need you then make that new dependency
the one you're going to use in the old
version and that generally tends to
break things because as well as the one
change that you needed in the common
library there's all the other things
that happened the last 18 months so you
end up having to back port in both your
library and your project and this kind
of totally undid the notion of the
utility of sharing this code because
every supported version of the product
had also a version of the common library
as well they were clearly linked
together we just chose them to bifurcate
them because we thought were future
proofing ourselves so my suggestion to
you to work around these problems is
don't have a common repository if for
example in our common it had everything
from mock time through the testing
helpers every possible thing you can
imagine each of those should be their
own project they should have the
separate repository version version them
independently that means you can upgrade
them and when you need a fix to one of
them you are much smaller surface area
you're changing
one of the other things I tend to pick
up in code of view of programmers who've
transitioned from other languages like
languages with a well-defined project
stroke package structure is that they
tend to your overuse packages now I
think the truth for all of us is go
programmers is that the that the path to
mastery of go is really the path to
being moderate in use of all your
features not just packages but channels
go routines interfaces being moderate in
all these features is something that
with experience you realize that's
that's actually the way to go but
package over you specifically seems to
be one of the common the common ones
that show up and that there's there's
some reasons why this is probably not a
probably not a good idea like why you
can't bring the way you used to organize
your code in Java over to go and one of
those reasons is that we don't have this
very elaborate visibility system Java
for example has public protected private
and default access modifiers they also
apply to the class as well as the method
there's a lot of different ways of
saying this person over here identify
very clearly can access can accesses
feel but this person to my right is not
allowed to do and go obviously we only
have public and private either you can
get to it if everyone can get to it or
no one can get to it there's there's one
there's one exception to that and I'll
come to that very soon so given that we
have this paucity of access controls how
what practices what guidelines should we
should we follow to avoid making over
complicated package hierarchies and the
advice that I find myself repeating the
most is to prefer when or when all
things are considered prefer fewer but
larger packages he saw he saw an example
earlier where I said we don't have a
HTTP slash client an HTTP slash server
an HTTP slash common the
purpose of the HTTP package is to
provide all things HTTP so this you
bring all those together another another
way of implicitly following following
this guideline is to say every package
with the exception of command and
internal should contain some source code
if you find yourself creating a package
hierarchy to be to create a very
detailed taxonomy where you put things
you put things in smaller and smaller
directories and thus those intermediate
or intermediate directory is empty it's
only the one at the end there has source
code that's a clue that you might be
overusing packages an example of this is
the package structure which seems to
have kind of leaked out and infected
other big go projects and it's really a
really a an aspect of history that was
just incidental because of the because
of the original way that we built go
code using make files we needed to put
all the source code in a particular
directory so we could have a recursive
make build and so the very first
versions that go shipped had a directory
called command which obviously had the
commands in it and a directory called
package which had everything else years
ago the standard library moved away from
this because we just didn't need it like
it was it was out of it was out of sync
with how go path work this was this
weird oddity in go route had this extra
slash package in there and also we
didn't need it because the go tool was
much more effective at building code
than than recursive make so my argument
to you is that the package is just like
putting I in front of interfaces
needless boilerplate it adds nothing
other than noise and the replacement
flap I'm going to talk about next which
is the internal directory
um this advice I just really really I
did that
it's the next thing if we're arranging
our packages by what they provide to the
caller what about the files inside them
like the the names of the files and how
many that you have are not obvious to
the not not obvious to the consumer
they're completely once the thing is
compiled they completely erased but are
there any guidelines which will help
which will help new readers navigate
through our source code and so these are
these the guidelines that that I follow
that I've been doing these for more than
five years now I think I think they're
they're pretty solid start start simply
new directory one file and we would go
maybe give it the same name as the
folder like that's a that's a good
default like if you chose a good package
name you don't need to you don't need to
overthink it and reinvest in making just
reuse the package name as the name of
the source code file it does seem to be
a little bit of duplication that the
page TP package also has a file called
HTTP also in the directory named HTTP
but given that you can't change two of
those things like white wine vent invest
the mental energy and thinking up a
fancy name for the package for that for
the source code file now as your package
grows you're probably going to find that
either just you don't like how long the
file is getting or you you you feel that
you want a different arrangement to help
logically split the source code into
different files by their responsibility
so that this when I said earlier think
of think of a package in Java as a
source code file in go this is an
implementation of that so
if you have if you have a messages file
so this is for some kind of RPC protocol
messages sucko contains things about
requests and responses clients contains
the kind of client client code and
server contains the server type another
pattern which either supersedes or
overlays with this one is to arrange
files by your import declarations now
you'll find that you probably have some
common imports across all your files io
and formed are usually good examples of
this but generally you can find files
you can find the code which is doing
network stuff and isolate that C so you
only have one file that imports the net
dependency that means the only network
stuff happens in that it can't happen in
any other file because you haven't
imported the net package and similarly
if you have stuff that does parsing
perhaps you know decoding decoding the
decoding the messages from the response
from the client to the server you
probably want to put those in a
different file so again so again you
split up the responsibility very simply
by the the imports in which they include
because they ultimately define what's
going to happen inside that that file
nouns are a really good name for source
code files files are after all
containers for code so they should
contain they should be nouns we call it
we container is a noun
book case is a noun they're nouns are
very good for source code
if if you're concerned that splitting a
file into many will affect your compile
time please don't worry about that
effectively when when the source code is
presented to the go compiler the go
compiler compiles each function in
parallel or at least parallel being the
number of CPUs you have it not per file
so splitting up by file will neither
increase nor decrease your compilation
time as I talked about there is there is
no implicit hierarchy with one exception
of packages net HCP is not a child of
the net package this is just this is
just a weak taxonomy there is no
relationship between them other than
just where the source code is stored and
to get back to the that the first piece
of advice which was avoid large sets of
blank intermediary directories if you
find you're doing that you might have
fallen afoul of a desire to create a
taxonomy like when you classify things
you create a classification then the
next thing to do is create sub
classifications and be even more
specific and even more specific and
that's interesting work but
fundamentally not where the value lies
all you're going to do is just have
longer import statements for no real
value
okay so as I alluded to a few times we
have the internal package who who knows
what I'm talking about when I say the
internal package yeah Jacob knows
everybody else does not okay
so so go code as we understand it today
if it's public anyone then world can
import it anyone can go get your package
and depend on your little utility
parsing function for layer four layers
deep that you never actually intended to
be part of your public API but given
that we only have exported and
unexploited go doesn't doesn't appear to
give us any way of saying this is helper
functionality only for my project please
don't depend on it that's exactly what
the what the internal directory is for
the go tool recognizes this special
folder name not a package name I see
it's not enough to call it package
internal the the name of the folder or
directory has to be internal and this
this can be used to indicate code that
is public to that part of your project
or usually your whole project but is not
public to the rest of the world so it's
a way of scoping the public symbols that
you have and saying they're not part of
my public API you cannot depend on the
you cannot import them to create an
internal package so-called stick it
inside a directory called internal who
can import it then only direct our
ancestors it's it's easier to it's
easier to show in text rather than to
try and describe the rules are quite
it's a simple rule but it's quite for
both simply if we have ABC internal d EF
only code that is routed ABC and
downwards from there can import ABC
slash internal anything so a B a B G d/f
all of those routes effective represent
other packages from other parts of
github and they're not the go-to will
not prompt I will not let you compile an
important that you are not a direct
sibling of so what what this what this
means fundamentally is you can create
internal packages with good descriptive
names that provide a set of funky
charity and you can also say that you
can also limit who can depend on them
and that's super critical because
everything in your public API is public
people will depend on it whether you ask
them to or not when when the internal
directory was being proposed I argued
strenuously that this should just be a
convention it shouldn't be a it
shouldn't be enforced by the go compiler
it shouldn't the go tool shouldn't know
anything about this if somebody does
this intentionally it's right there in
the name you know it's instead of
internal call it don't import and if you
import the thing called don't import or
then it's on you I can categorically say
that I was wrong this it has to be
enforced because otherwise otherwise
there is no there is no way that you can
avoid getting an issue on your on your
github repository two years after the
fact saying someone's like I was using
your internal hash function you deleted
it on me man you don't want to be in
that position you want by default
everything that you publish in your
package to be private in your very
selectively when you choose rather than
that rather than the semantics of
language choosing to make it available
to other people
I mean publishing if you have some code
which is grown in an internal package
making it public is as simple as just
moving it up one directory set on
directory that's all it takes and look
then but that's a deliberate action that
you take rather than letting you just
kind of fall out of writing the code
are there any sing-sing as few people
put up their hands about the internal
package of any questions about that I
could probably show examples if you want
yes correct
the question is about circular
dependencies how to break them when they
happen and my belief I mean the go tool
does not permit circular dependencies
Java does I'm pretty sure c-sharp does I
have no idea I don't believe Ruby or
Python does but that's kind of a the way
that their languages work JavaScript I'm
not sure but to make the language
simpler to make the compilation easier
go tool does not allow circle
dependencies now where do they come from
and why were you affected by them my
assertion to you is that circular
dependencies come from having too many
packages when you get into the situation
a depends on B and B depends on a your
only solution is to create a C third
package and move the things that they
need from each other into that one and
you've just made the problem worse now
you have three packages where were you
two and that program just that problem
balloons from their circular
dependencies are a design issue they're
not a limitation in the language they're
a fundamental design issue if I depend
on if if I need to ask you for
permission and you also need to ask me
for mission neither of us can get
anything done it's a it's a design issue
that shows up when the goat when the go
tool won't compile your your source code
so we should talk more but the the
simple answer that is when I when people
say I have the circular dependency
between these two the instinctual
response is I can break this by just
moving the code out the real response is
that you should look at the design and
say why why I say why they so tightly
coupled that they need to talk to each
other why is the dependency tree in
bi-directional it needs to be leads to
one direction
it's a it's a it's a symptom of a design
issue but we'll talk we'll talk later at
the end because I because I I know it's
I know it's simple for me to say oh you
just need to mode that merge those two
packages but I'm making a very difficult
situation seems simple um
the like the last point is the last
piece of advice is your package main
your command your function the thing
that holds your main domain should do as
little as possible and this is because
main domain is very special obviously
it's where the main entry point into but
it has a bunch of properties that make
it especially very difficult to test and
at both a function level and a package
level for example you cannot import
package main you cannot import it into
another package so you cannot use any of
the functions in that main package you
might have some helpers for like
checking errors or loading come on
config files you cannot reuse them
anywhere else because main cannot be
important and a main package cannot be
imported anywhere else um also main is
effectively a singleton that can only be
one main function in a program and you
also can't call that main function from
anywhere else don't forget it's
lowercase M so it's not public you can't
call it from anywhere else and because
it has this singleton behavior there are
a lot of assumptions that are just baked
into it the first one is that it will
only be called a finish at the start of
your program it will only be called once
it makes it very hard to write tests for
your main function or any code called
directly from your main function in that
package because of those first two rules
they don't expect to be called once and
it can't be called from anywhere else
main packages do a lot of other behavior
which is implicit any
this is the main function for my project
this this is only expected like like
what are the cases where this will be
initialized it's going to be initialized
by some code that's run from main so
that makes it super difficult to write a
test about because that initialization
will only happen once so I can have
exactly one test case that sucks main
packages either directly through the
main function or through and helpers
that they call generally expect to pass
command line flags which are again or a
singleton they expect files to be on
disk it's it's it's not uncommon to
hard-code a config file that's going to
make it super hard to test especially if
you want to test the parsing of that
config file for dear different values
that config file in parallel it's gonna
be very very hard to test so given all
these limitations my advice is that you
should aim to move as much of that
business logic everything except for
just pausing pausing your command line
flags you don't you maybe don't need to
write a test for test for that if you
use a command line parsing library like
why do you need to test what what
somewhat cover has been tested or or
kingpin has tested like you you can you
can pretty much assume that the actual
reading and parsing of flags is probably
going to work because that's been well
tested so really you want to read your
positive Flags open any like major
connections like set up your logger open
your connection to kubernetes or a
database or whatever the main things
that your program cannot possibly
continue without and then take all that
state and pass it to some other package
which has got the business logic you
want to move as much as possible out of
your main package because it's just a
pain to test
okay this isn't this isn't the last
point but it is the last area of design
advice that we're going to talk about
today we're going to move on to some
other some other aspects like error
handling and testing next
but of all the suggestions that I've
made so far
I think these they really are
suggestions because fundamentally with
the possible exception of the name you
give to public things all of that is
just like implementation details you can
refactor that you can fight about it in
code view you can move source code
between files you can move them in and
out of different packages it's probably
not going to be visible to the user but
for me when it comes to reviewing api's
public api's this is this is where I put
all my energy into the code review we
know we don't waste time talking about
names are arguing about indentation or
stuff like that I put all my effort into
reviewing the public API because that's
the only thing that matters for the
caller they can't see any of the rest of
it
now what now is this just like a
personal vendetta that I just really
give people a hard time about their
public API I think it's I think it's
justifiable because changing your public
API forces your user base to have to
dedicate engineering resources to
following your change if you if they
won't upgrade to the new version of your
library and their code doesn't compile
the first thing they're going to do is
roll back and if they were and depending
on that the size of the break the larger
that break is the more likely it is that
that's going to be pushed off to like
work that you should do later it's
fundamentally like if I've just
arbitrarily decided to rename things in
my API that's a low-impact change like
no function they get no new
functionality from upgrading to my new
version but it has a high risk they have
to change their code and this this then
creates the worst scenario that you have
users using old versions of your
software and that this this entire model
of I can I can check a fix into my
project on master and release a new
version breaks because you have people
using older versions and the longer they
stay on those older versions the more
dedicated they get to them they demand
back ports I am NOT gonna say Python to
seven but that's what I mean
your superpower is that you get to ship
those feet those fixes quickly and you
can only do that if the upgrades are as
painless as possible for your users if
they're if they're even slightly
difficult what what was previously a
simple change to a dependency management
file becomes a ticket with a t-shirt
size in an engineering backlog that just
won't get done so you can't get your API
right the first time
the more the bigger that you make them
the bigger the chance that you'll have
something you want to change but it
really pays to put your engineering
effort into thinking very clearly about
both the intent the behavior that you
want to promise and the unintended
behavior that's leaking out and I've got
some examples I love this Josh Bloch is
the technical if you was I Brian gets is
now the tech lead for Java for a long
time and that the summary of this entire
section is really this API should be
easy to use and hard to misuse how to
misuse is kind of obvious like like we
don't want to make it easy for people to
do the wrong thing but the easy to use
bit is the one that seems to trip people
up they seem to mistake flexibility the
ability to do a lot for ease of use
which has the ability to do the the
common thing the default thing easily
without prevarication
so here are some here are some examples
of hakken how you can mess yourself up
here are to two functions it's very
short
they have very simple simple API s1 is
very easy to use the other you have a
50% chance of getting it right what's
the difference between these two
functions well obviously one tells you
the maximum of two numbers the other one
copies files around now the thing about
max is that if I say what is what is
what is larger one dollar or ten dollars
is exactly the same question is what is
larger ten dollars or one dollar it's
commutative the order does not matter so
in that case it's okay for those two
parameters to be the same because it
doesn't matter even if I ask as I say
what is the maximum of eight and ten
what's ten what is maximum ten and eight
it's also ten let's compare it to the
copy file example
can you tell which is the right way to
do it
which one of these statements made a
backup of your presentation and which
one overrode your presentation with last
week's backup you couldn't even tell in
code review unless you were intimately
burnt by this constantly you would not
remember the order of the parameters the
the usual way that it works and go comes
ironically from the way it works in
assembly which is the register closest
to the instruction is the target but
like who's going to remember that so
that the the problem here is not that
that it wasn't well documented like
they're called to and from the problem
is that there is no the compiler cannot
help you and there's no way that a code
reviewer can know without consulting the
documentation did you get these
parameters right
I mean that the general advice is don't
do this like try very hard to avoid it
just like long parameter list sir design
smell if you have 7 8 15 parameters to a
method you know you've done it you may
know made a mistake but list of any size
of indistinct parameters are also a
design smell just as an exercise I tried
to find some way to fix this and that's
basically by defining a new type called
a source and there has a copy to method
so because it because it's kind as a
string we can say source is this and
then source copy to destination it kind
of that's kind of a cute fluent
interface but at least it present it
prevents you from calling copy file
incorrectly this also means that maybe
copy file we don't need to make it
public anymore we can hide its dangerous
nature and say it has to be called
through like copying a file is a useful
function but maybe we can hide the
ambiguity of its to-and-from parameters
by putting it behind some other kind of
helpers and types so fundamentally api's
with multiple parameters that the same
types are hard to use correctly
so in that example all the prep all the
parameters were required you have to you
have to have you have to have a source
and destination then there is no default
destination there's no default source
but most api's are targeted towards a
range of callers people who want from
the the most common behavior which is
the way that they're most commonly
invoked through to the most specialized
behavior and so a couple years ago I
gave a talk about using this functional
options pattern to make it easier to
make API as useful for their default
case it's basically mek a mechanism of
removing optional parameters they don't
show up in the parameter list you're
only required to supply the things that
have no reasonable defaults but the
underlying the the underlying message
from that talk was that you should
require callers to give you parameters
that they either don't know or don't
care about so many so many api is public
api as I read require you to pass in a
variable which is only used in uncommon
cases like and all the places you see it
copied that would just be a zero or
something like that so because you need
to supply that parameter the users have
guessed they're like well I don't know
what it is so what is what is like a
reasonable default well zero okay zero
what that's fine okay we're going we're
going on and the thing is because
they're guessing if they're lucky it has
no impact like if they guessed right has
no impact
if later on the that parameter which
they thought was unimportant something
becomes very very important they're now
explicitly saying zero which might zero
might be don't copy anything so they
can't they can't tell because the
behavior of the method has changed in
the signature say stayed the same so you
you can you can read the talk their
watch they I'm not going to reiterate it
there but that that the takeaways this
is the thing I pick up on you
design reviews the most every parameter
must be justified like that yeah they
really have to pay for themselves many
many times over if you have a parameter
which is optional I'll push the I'll
push the author to make a second second
type of function call you know with
such-and-such parameter with
such-and-such parameter because if that
is the unusual case like if most the
time you want the default behavior then
save the name like that the short name
of this function with the default
behavior and the least number of
parameters for the one that they expect
if occasionally you have to pass up with
an extra style or pass it with a
formatting parameter or pass it with the
width call it function with width and
that has the extra parameter under the
hood they probably dispatched to a
private method which does all the stuff
but you don't expose that complexity to
the user directly so let's give an
example and as I said it's I usually use
examples from the standard library
mainly because to the most extent
they're blameless many many people have
touched this code many many people have
reviewed it it's not a personal
statement on any engineer the HTTP
package is tremendously successful and
the successes mean that has grown V
approaches of extension and accretion
over time and that makes it really good
for these case studies of what happens
to packages over time as they grow like
how do seemingly inconsequential things
actually or as we'll see this example
well intended things actually turn out
to be bad ideas
so how many people know this listen and
surf method you've probably called it
like in a callow world hello world on
HTTP examples you call net dot listen
and serve you can hit some address colon
8080
and you either pass nil for the default
handler or you pass in your own handler
like it's you can write a hello world
that publishes on the web you know in a
few in a few minutes um so this would
seem to be a tremendously successful API
you can't you can write a hello world in
four or five lines so what is it what is
there to pick on in here it takes two
parameters the address and a handler
which is that the root of your outer
that your routing tree now serve also
has a second parameter which is the
router if you want or if you pass nil it
will use this thing called default serve
MUX which is a public variable inside
the HTTP package so here coming back to
what Dave Thomas said earlier you now
have a situation where this thing does
two things it listens and serves and if
you haven't given it a cheapy handler it
will do some different behavior
so what this means is you can call it
like this or we can call it like that
and it does exactly the same thing so
that's weird I mean the you you have
what is an optional parameter so this is
an example of an optional parameter but
it turns out that if you actually don't
know what the value for the optional
parameter is then listen and server will
implicitly use default serve marks and
the reason the reason this nil is here
is actually viral it comes from HTTP
serve so listen and service just help
her that wraps listen and serve right in
this name so the nil comes from the fact
that serve if you pass nil into it will
actually use default HT did default
default serve MUX
but
you might be forgive me for thinking
well I can pass nil in the right
parameter so why can't I pass nil on the
left permit like nil means in the second
position means use the default but if I
pass nil in the left position it panics
if I just gives you an ugly panic so the
prop that the problem is that we kind of
suggested and many of the examples that
you see online say nil goes in the
left-hand column so you could be
forgiven for thinking well no goes nil
means default this one should listen on
localhost I guess that's the default
passed nil for that so that the
takeaways don't mix nil and non ailable
parameters in this function signature
I'm gonna argue later don't have a pass
nil at all but certainly if some of the
parameters permit nil and others don't
don't mix them together either
everything allows a nil or nothing does
now what the author of listen itself was
trying to do is make your life easier
like like these eight lines you have to
remember I mean there are more than
there's there's more than just typing
the mean you have to know it's TCP you
have to know the value of that listen
you need to pass the word TCP to it you
need to you need to remember to close
the listener and and that the defer is
kind of special because you need to know
that serve actually blocks so they are
doing a little bit of a little bit of
work for you they were trying to do the
right thing but really there's no
difference between these three lines
and these three lines except that there
are two ways to do it like this saves
nothing there's a this is already a
public variable the the nil just
encourages people to to say I don't know
I don't know what that value should be
let's try an ill and what's this really
actually just default so much really
help it's only saving one line so these
these are the kind of discussions I'll
have in code review where people are
trying to make their throw api friendly
but they they get ahead of themselves in
thinking well how how would I like to
write this in the most concise way and
they miss the fact that they are making
their API more more ambiguous and this
admits unintended behavior
this yes yeah correct yeah so the
question is what if what if your
argument is the end of is an interface
type well you know know kind of
satisfies by that it's more that this is
probably perhaps poorly worded I don't
mean nillable as in nil fits in a in a
pointer type where it doesn't fit in a
value type I mean don't mix fields which
are permitted to be nil with fields
which are not permitted to be nil but
I'm gonna argue strenuously just don't
ever pass nil for for a parameter it's
just always the wrong answer
another place that this this shows up is
in public API would test only parameters
these are things like if your thing does
something with the network or if your
thing like writes to a database it's
it's tempting to have a parameter to say
you know don't actually touch the
database so write it so that there'll be
like somewhere and there some kind of
parameter like false or you know
read-only or something like that that is
really only used in a test context if
that's the case make that you take that
function make it private and have have
two callers one one which passes the
pleaseplease rewrite in the main code
and in the test in the test function
have a different version of it that
passes false so if there's something
about your API that makes it hard to
mock you down string dependency and you
actually have to have a kind of
safeguard inside the code itself to say
don't please don't actually commit these
transactions while I'm trying to run my
tests because that'll mess up my
fixtures don't expose that to users in
any way and you'll you'll see those
you'll see these show up really really
easily because all of the implications
of a particular API in main code in your
real code will have one value for that
magic don't write parameter and in your
tests it'll always have a different one
the value of that the value of that
magic parameter says please don't write
please don't write this data back to the
database or please read think think of
doing mirror traffic you want to read
the rest you want to read the request
and process it but you don't wanna send
the response back because the main
servers actually done that you you can
easily spot those in your test code
because in the tests it's always in one
direction and in the main code it's
always in the opposite direction so
that's a real smell of parameters which
affect the testing that should never be
exposed to the user
another another one that shows up a lot
is when you need to pass several of
things this this is a semi made-up
example but it's based on code we've
worked on that did a lot of interactions
with cloud api's and they always have
lists of VMs to read or write or things
like that the thing is what while this
will down in VMs in a single call almost
all the time it was called in code and
especially in the test code we only ever
passed one so that meant that we had to
for that single value that we had we had
to wrap it in a slice just so we could
pass it through the passes through the
interface would pass us through that the
function parameter and the second thing
is that because this is a slice and you
can pass nil or an empty slice that
gives you an extra thing you have to
test what if someone calls shut down VM
with no VMS you can you can easily write
the code to deal with that but it's
another unintended consequence of
exposing that API
I'll give you another example that I was
recently working on it's just it's a
little bit ugly because the names are
long but effectively the logic boiled
down to this
if machs connections greater than zero
or max requests or max pending requests
so if one of these four parameters was
nonzero now you can imagine how this
function grew it started with max
connections and then as we added max
requests and then so it grew slowly over
time to the right
and it it also doesn't really tell us
what what we do I mean it these are
relatively well named so a reading of
reading of this like you read it two or
three times you're like oh it's the
individual logic is not important like
the values of max requests or max
connections are not important it's
simply the fact that one of them is
positive so what we actually want to do
is extract that logic we want to call it
we can make a little helper like this
that says that says if any of these
values and we just range over them it's
greater than zero then we say yes one of
them is positive and we can refactor the
function like this it's still it's still
a bit long I mean maybe you could break
it into multiple lines or something like
that but it's a little bit clearer like
like it reads like English if any of
these are positive then do this behavior
but because because we made this very
attic you can call it with none you can
call it with no arguments and in the
case of the code above it would return
false because you get no iterations
through that loop
so this isn't the worst thing in the
world but it's kind of like like a
nonsense nonsensical question what is
the maximum of no numbers you don't know
that you that you can't compute that so
we want to make it so that this helper
function any positive can never be
called with less than one value a little
bit more code in the helper we'll just
deal with first and then we deal with
the rest and that means that you can't
write this function with less than one
parameter it's first and then rest
the next one goes to I talked a lot
about defining behavior in terms of
interfaces and this is this is an
example of it let's say we've been given
a task to so we have this document who
knows what kind of document it is but
we've given then given the task to write
itself
to disk so I want to serialize the
document to disk and so I sit down at my
editor and I come up with this I say we
had a method called save and you pass in
the file you want it to save - okay that
gets the job done but it presents a set
of problems the first one is that the
signature save must go to a file because
that's the only thing that can be an OS
dot file you can if you're very very
clever get a UNIX path but realistically
the first thing that's going to happen
is someone say well can I write this to
the network or can I can I keep this
kind of write this out to memory because
I want to test it because of that save
is really difficult to test because to
validate that it's operation worked you
have to poop a file out on disk so you
have to create a temporary file pass it
to save call save and then read the file
back and compare it to what you want it
sorry I went saying it's gonna poop a
file anymore that's sorry Jacob I'm
so that that's just annoying that you
you have to create temporary files that
you have to make sure they're cleaned up
and if to make sure that they're not
written concurrently and all those
things but moreover our stop file has a
lot of methods that aren't really
relevant to save like it's it's the
representation of a UNIX file descriptor
so it can do things like you can ask is
this file a symlink
or if this file represents a directory
give me the directory entries and these
are not things that save should be
responsible for doing or actually
capable of doing so what is the go way
to to kind of solve this we can change
the signature or save to be an interface
and this this solves both of those
problems the first thing that rather
than passing a concrete file we say you
must possibly something that is a
read/write closure which is the relevant
things that finally things can do this
means that save can be used anywhere
that you have a read/write closer and
also means that save no longer has the
option to call those methods on files
like reading directories and symlinks
and changing permissions which means
that we know it can't do those things
because we always said to you is you can
read you can write and you can close
now if we take this idea further well
why does save need to read like like if
if save was verifying the father it
wrote out it might it might do that but
then it's not really it shouldn't be
called save it could should be cause
save and verify or something like that
so we can keep restricting the scope of
save down by removing things from the
interface that we give it we would take
off the permission to read and therefore
we guarantee that it can't read what it
just wrote because it shouldn't need to
that should be a different a different
function now what about the closed
behavior
close close presents a lot of a lot of
ambiguity because if we're saying save
has the ability to close the thing we
passed into it we're next the next
question is well when is it going to do
that that's something that you can only
really specify in documentation you
might have to say is very complicated
logic of save will close the file unless
there was an error or blah blah blah but
if save closes the file on success then
that means I can't use I can't use the
writer that I passed in to save to write
anything else out afterwards which means
I can't I'd use it for streaming data on
the network because as soon as I use it
once it's gonna close the network
connection so again we want to keep
making the interface we passed down to
save smaller we want to remove save
we could we could do a bunch of
shenanigans with with an interface I
create a kind of no up closer that when
you call closed it doesn't actually
close but that's some that's that that's
what we can do it easier if we just say
save doesn't get a write write closer
just gets a writer so the writer we now
know that save can do nothing but just
write data to this stream it doesn't
know anything about where that stream is
it could be a network could be a bytes
buffer it could be a file could be
anywhere
and so by pieing what turns out to be
the interface segregation principle
we've made a function that's the most
specific in what who wants to do it only
gets to write things it says it right
there in the method it can't do anything
else but right also it's the most
general it can write to anything and
then once once we've done this analysis
maybe it turns out that save isn't the
right name maybe it should be right too
I don't know that's just a that's just a
throwaway thought that now it's not
saved to file it's actually write to
writer maybe maybe that's a better name
okay nil is absolutely fascinating it's
something that something I think most
people in go either a scared of or they
take for granted that I really really
look too deeply into it but nil is the
most bizarre thing in the world for
example you can't compare nil to itself
both equal equality or inequality Neel
is not just not equal to itself in the
way that nan is not equal to itself
literally you can't write that code that
will not compile its even though we
always use era not equal to nil you
can't write nil not equal to nil that's
just it it does not support those
operators yet bizarrely nil can appear
on either side of a binary operation you
can say if R equals nil or if nil equals
error it's the most bizarre thing
so given all these restrictions like why
the hell would we have kneel and go this
is something that people come in from a
functional background are very upset
that go has this concept of an illness
it seems as an affront my my
interpretation of that is mainly coming
from other languages I'm gonna I'm going
to call out Java here that over users
nil people are terrified of no pointer
exceptions in Java because they happen
all the time and the reason they happen
all the time
is that in Java you use nil for a
failure condition the thing worked or I
gave you back in it I gave you back a
nil and we'll see an example of that in
a little bit but Neal has a lot of a lot
of good use cases like if you assign nil
to a pointer the point at one point or
anything like you need a way of saying
of disconnecting a pointer or saying
this memory is no longer referenced you
need a concept like that if your site
Neal to an interface the interface won't
point to anything same with you point to
a slice you free that slice you need you
need this concept
under the hood Nils meaning which type
is determined from the up from the other
parts of the expression so for example
when we say F equals nil that actual nil
is coerced into a OS file that points to
nothing
the same nil later on we say the string
equals nil its coerced into a slice of
string thing so nil has a very strong
relationship with the zero value but the
main thing that trips up go programmers
is this awful thing called the type nil
I've argued in the go to the go-to
discussions that we should we should
work to abolish the the type nil I
haven't got a lot of support in that but
I do need to tell I need to explain
what's happening here so in this code we
don't check the area that that's that's
the actual problem but the result is if
though if that path was if we open
failed we're ignoring the error so the F
we're going to give back is nil now the
thing is the type of F is an OS dot file
it's not a writer
I always start open returns a star OS
dot file so that's going to be a nil OS
file and so what is happening when you
return F there that nil the nil OS file
is being passed boxed into a writer so
the type in the interface will be OS dot
file and the value will be nil and this
is where this is where all goes terribly
wrong because nil is a nil type and a
nil nil pointer and F is a OS dot file
type and a nil pointer you can see just
by that explanation they're not the same
do I have an example that I don't have
an example that but the the the trick
there is if you are if you have a
concrete type say I should probably
rewrite that to be better um in fact let
me rewrite it and you'll see exactly
what I mean
shall we in one before error handling
API design
yes yes I know someone else's gotta open
I don't care
and my control master myself it's going
to bed
okay this is much clearer you can see
that the value returned from our stott
open must be appointed to a file it has
to to compile so if that is nil we have
a nil OS dot file that nil our sub files
being boxed inside the right inside the
interface and interfaces to words then
they the identifier for the type and the
value that's how type assertions work it
knows the interface holds a reference to
the type that was put into it and so now
here this is where the type nil comes
from and the simple answer to that is if
you're ever in that situation you
mustn't you you you might you mustn't
return the value of F in the error
condition you must always return
explicitly nil I should have a better
fit error for that oh I'll do an example
at the end of this I think I actually
have some better ones down here but that
the the sad truth is that we have to
deal with type Nils
okay we have two sections left um air
handling it's really important it's as
important as the rest of your code it's
as important as checking checking the
loop condition or check it or checking a
shift because fundamentally it's not
different type of coding fundamentally
it's just normal code just like string
manipulation or shifting it's your
responsibility
why doesn't go have exceptions
exceptions obfuscate control flow
they're non-local return when an
exception happens you can jump out of
many many many many many stack frames in
one go so they give you a different way
of the the CPU moving through the code
reliable software cannot be written with
unchecked exceptions I make this
statement because we have C++ in C++ you
can have they if you watch any of the
C++ conference talks they like someone
like Herbst that will get up on stage
and you'll have you'll have a simple
thing like like adding two strings
together like you know a plus B you know
say just you look at the audience you'll
say is this code safe adding two strings
together and it turns out that no
because the customer mutation restrain
could throw an exception in an uncaught
copy constructor all this nonsense in
C++ because exceptions are not required
to be declared
now of course Java came along and said
well this is this is the big problem
that I don't know by looking at your
function if it's going to call some code
that's going to throw an exception so
we're going to make everybody check
their exceptions if your think throws an
exception you'd write it in the you
write it in the function signature
therefore everybody knows that and
you're forced to check it the problem
with that is that that had terrible
implications for interfaces when when
they came up when they came along
you either have if you implement
interface that has a throws Clause in it
then you have to you you you you you
must you you can both only use
exceptions of the type that it says it
throws and you must only use exceptions
that type that throws the opposite is
the collections types which do not throw
in exceptions therefore they say the
compiler says these collections using
them like an iterator or
that an iterator or a range object does
not throw an exception which is great
except if you want to create an iterator
over something like JSON data reading
from a network which could have a
problem so
I could rathole on this for a long time
but the fact is no other language other
than Java has implemented checked
exceptions I believe this to be true
given that every way usually agrees that
unchecked exceptions are bad because you
don't know if any code is going to call
them and nobody else has tried to use
checked exceptions because of the
problems that you have had with them I
defy you to count with a reasonable a
reasonable for a way for how exceptions
can be used they sound great on paper
but 25 years of practice in three
different programming languages have
shown that they're not now in go we
don't use exceptions we have error
values we take advantage of the fact
that we have multiple returns this is a
thing which in the world of compiled
languages I would say around the time
that go was out was almost unique you
hope you have tuples and things like
that in Python but because of most of
the history of most of the compiled
language is going back to C which
returned a value in the ax register just
a single register was part of the
calling convention almost all languages
had only one return value now ago we
have multiple returns and so we have the
facility to make to pass back a thing
and an error value when necessary and as
well talk a little bit about um panic
and recover and just kind of how weird
they are because some people look at
panic and say well that's just let's
just try and catch with just different
names but the panic and recover are so
specialized and so weird they're off in
during corner
so recover can only be used like you can
call panic anywhere you want it does one
thing it caught it cause causes your
program Duncan to attempt to
unconditionally exit it's fair enough
you can use panic anywhere you want you
can it's a normal statement but recover
you can only write recover in one place
you can only write recover inside a de
fer block the compiler will not let you
use that word anywhere else and the only
reason why you would use recover is to
recover from a panic so that there's
this bizarre pair of features which kind
of live by themselves often the end you
shouldn't look at them as saying well
that's the natural error handling
behavior all these this nonsense with
multiple returns is just that that's
just noise the natural behavior is panic
and recover that's just not true they're
not designed for that
please go Joe Joe say talk to gopher
Khan about this idea known as hi Ohm's
law which is named after an ex-googler
called Hiram Wright who noted that with
a large enough user bases of your API
they will eventually come to depend on
every possible aspect of that API
whether your intended or not and we've
definitely seen that play out and go
over the last 10 years and one of the
ways that you can really blow yourself
up on this when it comes to error
handling is being is being too specific
about the area going to return so error
is just an interface but interfaces
every value every value that influence
an interface has a type so the first
thing you can do is you can say is this
a specific kind of error seem seem seems
natural I you have a very generic
interface error interface and you can
type assert and say is this a network
error or a URL error you can kind of try
and look into it and say I think you're
going to give me one of these and this
is what happens
so I have an issue to 886 HTTP GET says
it's documentation that you will return
it it will always return types of URL
error net URL error HTTP dot you're
actually I'm just gonna open it
I can finally cosa
and the problem there is that meant that
if the underlying the thing that the
HTTP client was connected to returned a
different error we had to stuff that
insight so like a network error we had
to stuff that inside the URL error
because we've been very specific and
said you will always get a type an error
of this type we were not permitted from
ever returning any other kind of error
and this caught us multiple times we
have to have a lot of testing around
this to make sure that every single
possible way that HTTP GET can return
returns this very specific error type
for no good reason other than we'll just
thought were being helpful a URL error
includes both the underlying error and
the URL you were trying to get to we
were trying to do the right thing but by
being too specific
we now could not could never change
anything about the implementation of
HTTP GET so if you want to avoid things
like that my overriding advice is don't
assume you know anything about the type
of the error either the error is nil in
which case the call worked or it is not
nil not equal to no that's all you know
the call failed if you try and dig more
into that I know there are cases where
in database systems and in internal
libraries you do want to be more more
prescriptive about that you are being
very tightly coupling the implementation
which may be many many layers of cool
air down in many different packages your
very tightly coupling yourself to that
so if you shouldn't check the type what
should you do what one one suggestion I
have and this is this is very much an
area that that will change and go 1.13
if the errors proposal lands I've been
off the air for a little bit then it's
not clear if it's actually he's going to
land there's a sustained backlash from
people who've seen the implementation in
113 and are not happy they they want
they want more thinking about it but so
we'll just talk about the world the
world as it is today
there are a small number of cases where
you can't just say oh the arrow wasn't
nil that's fine it failed that's all I
know there are a few cases where you
need to you need to know a little bit
more and one of those for example would
be is this a temporary error like my my
client API is trying to call yours the
cloud was down for now second the call
failed you need you need some way of
saying is this temporary failure like if
I just try again is that okay
or is this a permanent failure now
whether you you actually implement that
at the edge of your behavior or some
kind of intermediary like kind of
retrial library in the middle something
still need something still wants to
check is this it was that a temporary
error and the suggestion I have is
communicate properties of your errors
not with the type but with additional
behaviors that they implement for
example the net error type has a
function called it called timeout which
returns true if the error if the error
occurred because the other end timed out
because of that we can construct an
interface in line and say the error or I
was given has someone put a timeout
method on it if it is then we'll ask the
timeout would ask the timeout method
where you actually the timeout and this
means that you don't need to specify
that the only thing passed into is
timeout will be net errors anything
which has a timeout behavior on it can
do now this might seem quite
short-sighted because you're saying well
what are the the possible range of type
of behaviors timeout do you know retry
ball error lit like like many there
could be many many possible behaviors to
describe by this but in practice when we
actually survey the go code base timeout
and temporary cover almost the majority
of the set like like when you're saying
an error happened but is it okay to
try again these two seem to suffice so
if you do declare your own arrow types
and this is not is this not for every
single possible package that you do if
it is temporary sticker sticker kind of
a temporary method on there and then you
can write a helper where you need to
check and that's usually at the top of
your go team was that a temporary area
and you have you know nothing about the
type that's actually being used you're
just communicating via an interface
and I feel okay there two more here but
this this comes back to what it opened
with that using nil to indicate an error
is a big design smell now let's give
some background here well go programmers
discover that you can call a method on a
nil receiver it generally blows their
mind because they're used to Java with
virtual method with a V with a V table
pointer sorry
C++ already table pointer with Java
where you can't call a method are nil
reference but in go can go calling you
know bar dot whoa
and calling whoa with a bar is exactly
the same and in fact under the hood this
is what a method is we just take the
receiver and we make an implicit first
parameter so while this might seem
bizarre like whoa I caught a I I called
a method are nil receiver this is quite
this is fine it's like oh I passed new
offer for world but it didn't use the B
parameter anyway so that's not that's
not strange at all
so when you reset it like this it's
clear to see that passing nil for the
receiver is uneventful but where the
problem arises obviously if you try and
touch B if you try and use some
properties and you're going to do that
on methods because you wouldn't put that
method on a on a type unless you
actually intended to use bits of that
type if it didn't if that if that method
didn't reference its receiver in any way
he doesn't need to be a method it's just
a function and this this is where this
is where people will come unnerved
because it's going to panic on this line
and it's going to say that the problem
was here look B was nil that's why I
crashed but the actual programming error
was here it should report the error here
but it but you don't get that error
reported there and the reason the reason
is that the programming error actually
appeared right here we didn't initialize
bar so when we tried to dereference B to
get the message that's why it panicked
so the problem is not the go allows
allows you to call methods with a nil
receiver it's the fact that we
accidentally use nil in the first place
it's an interesting use of the spelling
of the word grip but okay um so when
when go programmers first come across
this just like when they come across the
type nil they grip with this this panic
that because this could happen and
there's no real protection inside beside
the language for it this is going to
happen all the time and the code is
going to be unreliable so how would you
defensively program against this the
first case is usually to put some kind
of check inside the method like oops
you know you caught if if bar is not nil
so you didn't accidentally pass no for
me then I'll print out the message I'll
make sure I can never crash by never
dereferencing D pressing B if it's nil
but the real solution is to realize that
that check should happen before you call
that thing and and I'm going to make a
case I'm going to make a case for why
and it's to do with when you're inside
that method or you've been passed a nil
receiver what really are your are your
choices well the first one is if someone
if B is nil and we don't want to
continue execution we can panic and say
B is no you should not call me call me
with a nil receiver
but given that dereferencing that field
anyway is going to panic anyway apart
from having a little more control over
the panic message this is this is just
needleless ceremony it's neither
defensive programming because you're
still panic
nor nor is it out really adding anything
so what about what about we said well
this is go we have multiple returns if
if there's an error like if we say that
this is not a panic worthy condition
this is just a programming error so we
say if billers vehicle's no then we're
going to return an error saying hey you
called me with an ill with a nil beam
but this has serious serious implication
if you're saying well this is the way
that we're going to work forever from
now on this has serious implications
every method every method has to return
an error just so that you could
potentially report to the caller whoops
you called me with nil every caller has
to check that error after every single
method is that you think people complain
about goes there handling now just wait
you have to check on every single method
clearly that's not workable worse every
interface you define will have to
include an error parameter so that any
implementation can do this behavior and
the opposite is that there are a bunch
of interfaces of ready to find an
already in use in the standard go
library which don't have this error
parameter so what are you going to do
then like do you are you going to be
selective about when you check or you
just not going to use those interfaces
like this is not an answer it's not
practical
so we saw above that whoops is going to
print nothing if there's a no receiver
it's only going to execute its gonna do
a precondition it's going to check its
it's going to check is is my receiver
correct okay then it's okay I can go and
do reference message so it's going to
use that that guard Clause that we
talked about earlier and argue to this
is perhaps the worst choice of all if
though the other two weren't bad enough
is the worst choice because the
operation will silently do nothing
now imagine try a debugger complex
failure when just bits of your
application don't run because you have
nulls leaking in places so given this a
reasonable way for a method to execute
against being called our nil receiver my
my case to you is just don't try because
that's not actually the problem the
problem is where that nil came from
don't try and fix it after the fact it
came from not checking an error
it's the
in the last six years of programming go
every day this is ultimately where all
those nails come from not checking the
error and we have the good news is we
have great tools for that all the
linters will check if you don't if you
don't check and handle an error all you
need to do is pass your to your code
through go to a vet and you'll never
have this problem
and equally you shouldn't write your
method your functions or anything to
return nil as some kind of signifier for
to return nil to say Oh an error
happened the the most classic one in
Java is string string substring if you
sub if you mate if you ask for a
substring that's out of range so you
have a very small string and you're
after the one five characters to the
right it returns nil so you have this
nil which is silently leaking around
your code base until someone touches it
the good news is that we just don't that
have that in go for the simple case of
well strings can't be nil for a start
the second one is that we have multiple
return values and this guerra this
eliminates the need to use nil as a or
something bad happened Sentinel
so the bottom line don't check for no
receiver get good test coverage use your
vet and lean tools and you just won't
have that problem and so that that's
when I talk about and I will go quicker
because I choose a trail on time on that
I'm Dara handling strategy we have is
using the air interface not panic um
because panic is not an appropriate type
of control flow the there are two or
three cases inside the standard library
where panic is used and none of them are
for errors they are to simulate
non-local control in the in the JSON
encoding package because it's a
recursive thing they use they use panic
to quickly leave all those stack frames
it's not it's I doubt we doubt in what
would write it like that these days
but that's that's how it was written and
so the only cases inside the standard
library where panic and recovery used
like that are to simulate non-local
return
so the fundamentally is that panic must
truly be the last resort you it's used
only if the conditions are impossible
like a like I can't happen here division
by zero those kind of things worse than
panic in your own code is a panic from a
library nothing is going to be worse for
the NGO ecosystem than if people start
to think other library code I need to
protect against it kind of panicking
happily by wrapping it all in a recover
I mean another thing is that panic
unwinds the stack in which it happens
you can't recover it from a different
stack and so it it's an incredibly hard
thing to use as a as an error recovery
mechanism to the point that just don't
use it like use use error values
and a sneaky way that panics actually
sneak in is the low package has faithful
and panic now panic is obvious but
faithful is less obvious fatal just
prints out a message and then cause
panic in my in my opinion there is no
there is a reason for a login package to
be able to crash your package it just
shouldn't be there there just a mistake
and given given that you could easily be
be forgiven for thinking like we have
debug.warning era panic or era fatal if
you think that's just another logging
level except this one there's one line
and crash any go program in the world ok
will whoa ok that's alright
yes okay we've got half an hour left and
I'm going to give some examples here
all right this so we spent an awful lot
about talking about how to handle errors
what's the right way to do it how to
inspect them but the best thing about
error handling is just not having to do
it in the first place and so these two
examples of inspired by John Astor House
book about how equals are define errors
out of existence
so in these ones we're going to look at
two bits of code and we're going to just
make it see it I have to check the error
not by ignoring it but just making it so
there is no error so let's let's have a
function that counts the number of lines
we pass it in a reader and it's just
going to loop over loop over the reader
County counting lines as it goes until
we get to the end of the file the count
is the number of lines
at least that's the code that we want to
write but their their handling isn't
correct in this code there are there a
bunch of problems for example we
increment the count of lines before
checking the error that looks weird
while we do that like every single other
place and go with the exception of the
read type methods we check the error
first and then we don't touch the other
values why do we do it this way
the reason is how do we how do we count
a file that doesn't have a trailing
newline
we have to we're basically counting the
number of times we call read string not
the number of lines we read
I think there's an example missing there
okay there is an example missin they all
have to put it there afterwards
now in Ross's era suppose the last year
he made a good case that in most of the
cases error handling can obscure the
operation the file this is the code that
you want to write what a some type the
number of lines and say for every single
line you can increment the counter and
so the simple fix to this was not to
somehow improve the error handling will
come up with clever handling it was to
use a better type and this is the whole
reason why Reed Reed string are
discouraged because they're just too
hard to use we have the scanner and the
scanner works as we expected
the scan method returns true if it has
matched a line of text and not
encountered an error so the body of our
for loop is only called where there are
lines of text in the scanners buffer
this means it correctly counts when
there are low lines of text in the
buffer the previous version would start
at one even if we read no lines
but more germane to this discussion is
scan returns false once an error is
encountered so we don't need to check
the error every single time we read the
line that's abstracted away hidden
inside the scanner if you want to get
the error back out we just need to check
it once using the SEO error method an
SEO error nicely handles turning AOF
that's expected when you get to the end
of a file into a nil so that we don't
even need so that we can clearly handle
that we don't even need to check what AC
dot error our is if the file ended as
expected not we hit some kind of i/o
error around our disk base we we just
get the nil as we expect
the second example this will talk to all
about reading let's talk about writing
so imagine we have some kind of server
some kind of HTTP HTTP type server and
somewhere in the guts of our code is
this thing called write response which
takes a writer
status headers and a body which is the
components of the HTTP message so first
thing we have to do we have to write out
the HTTP status code and check the error
blah blah blah then feature the headers
we have to write the header out and
check the error blah blah blah then we
have to then we have to include a
trailing newline because that's how HTTP
works and check the error and then
lastly we have to copy the body and this
time not check the error
so the thing is that not is there a lot
of repetitive error checking in there
every single diff every single error
check was slightly different its have a
quick look at him again this one is just
a straight air check this one happens in
a loop this one because this one is
slightly different formed and this one
we don't check the only reason that we
have it on two lines is because copy
returns two parameters and we only need
one so it's just a bit of syntax of the
language forces on us don't forget also
we have different errors declare
different scopes written in idiomatic
code this in idiomatic go there is still
a lot of a lot of noise there
so how can we make this better we can
just put a little type in the middle of
it we have this thing called an arrow
writer and this is derived from a blog
post on the Go Go blog which uses a
similar a similar type and a slightly
different example so arrow writer is in
caption illusion over a writer and it
keeps in error and so any work where we
use like the regular IO writer we can
substitute our writer which if there's
no if a previous right through this
error writer had failed we just return
the error if if not we we attempt the
right to the underlying writer keep that
error and continue on that's imp that's
the important thing we never return
we never return an error from this
writer because we never want even though
our code can now just ignore the area of
this writer was then passed to something
else we know what we don't want it you
imagines this writer was somewhere in
the chain of gzip gzip and adjacent
encoder and something else like that it
still has to fulfill the writer contract
so even though we're kind of memorizing
the error we still have to keep we still
have to fulfill the contract but look
how this dries up the right response
method we just construct our writer over
the one we were given and then just we'd
literally get to write the code that we
want print the use F printf to print the
the status message iterate over each of
the headers write the additional head
write the additional R and n copy the
body we don't even need to care about
the response from copy and then because
that's captured inside the O writer and
then finally return arrow write adult
error so that this this is this is my
interpretation of hasta halts comment of
define errors out of existence we've
changed we haven't just said we're not
checking the errors we've changed the
way though we've changed the way of code
usually by inserting or choosing a
better type that means we just have to
check less often and that means that
there's less error handling code to fill
up
you're the what is very prescriptive
business logic here like this is the
form of they should be message you have
to be very specific there yes
well the thing is if there was an error
this is going to be no op no it'll yeah
it's you you spent you'll potentially if
there was an underlying error writing
the first thing you are spending a
little bit more time so it's the
question of how likely do you think that
they will actually ever be an error I'm
making the argument that errors occur
but as a percentage are relatively
infrequent like the total type like if
you've got a busy web server the total
time spending process like sending
responses to the other side that is
disconnected is going to be nonzero but
of the total number of like if you're
only handling a few responses the the
microseconds to make make a few no of
course is trivial and if you're making a
large number a large number of calls the
number that you expect to fail if this
is true the number you expect to file
should be low so it's very like it's
very unlikely that this is going to do
unnecessary work if you expect them to
always fail if you expect 50% of your of
your of your requests to file you can
show in profiling that you're spending
too much time sending doing doing a
little bit of string formatting to send
to the other to just throw on the floor
then yes you probably shouldn't use this
mechanism but I doubt that that is going
to be your performance problem if it is
you know exactly where to fix it you
can't use this nice since you have to
have a big comment that says we have to
check after every one because half of
these requests half these responses
always fail because our clients always
disconnect
but I don't know about your situation
you seem to be very concerned about the
performance and that's very that's very
important but if if that failed often
yes that would be a lot of ways to work
but errors are not the you have to check
because something could file but that
doesn't mean it's always going to file I
would have to fall back on let's
actually profile it like that is really
not a lot of wasted work um
and yes I I do need to move on the last
one in this section is only handle and
arrow once what do I mean by handling an
arrow once I mean checking the error
like like some value of checking
checking checking the air in this
example we're not checking the air at
all we're throwing it away from right so
making less than one decision ignoring
the error is definitely in the station
no but you should never ignore the error
unless it's a very deliberate choice
like there's no comment say we ignore
the error because we know it being
passed above friend won't ever return an
error that's just wrong wrong wrong your
written code but equally this here is
not right either what's happening here
is if the air is no we're writing a line
to a log file and we're returning the
error this is what I mean this is the
argument that I make that this handles
the error and that handles the error by
passing it back to the caller you can
imagine you can imagine the output if
every single function in the call chain
logged the error and passed it up to a
caller who logged it again and passed it
out to the caller in fact I can tell you
exactly what that looks like that looks
like the start of a JIRA the people are
sniggering you know exactly what I mean
that the the the Java pattern of log and
exception and pass it back and and re
throw it tells you nothing
as I said the caller is probably doing
the same thing and so all you get is
just what is effectively a materialized
stack trace couldn't write it because IO
AOF couldn't write the config because IO
AOF and at the top you're pro just
printing it out anyway
and apart from the verbosity which is
really just a just a political statement
the problem with logging and returning
is that it is super easy to forget to
return it's okay if you forget to log it
if you forget to return
it's the it's the overall pattern of log
and return that makes it too easy the
the important bit is not the log line
it's completely unimportant the
important bit is the proper error
handling by not continuing in this
function
so only hear it handle the error once if
you check is erekle nil or
do some kind of assertion like is it a
timeout then you're only allowed to make
one action if you log it
you shouldn't return it now that's
rarely going to be the case that's
really gonna be case that's the right
thing to do normally when there's an
error you can't continue with the rest
of your function so the only thing you
can do is return so by definition don't
log it just return it and a bunch of
stuff is happening obviously the go
errors changes which aren't going to
include the stack trace which is
probably what a lot of a lot of this log
and return kind of behavior it's
manually constructing a set of
breadcrumbs like where were you in this
panicked because at the top if you just
print i OE o f you have no idea where
this came from and of course that was
the genus for the package errors package
that i wrote which was inspired by a
dozen others to do the same thing so
this is an area it's going to change
with the 1.13 error changes because
errors will have a stack frame and be on
a point to where they came from it's
just not clear if that's going to happen
this release or the reese ofter if it's
going to be reworked so now we have now
we have a choice I have about 10 minutes
like we really can't go past really
can't go past about 5:30 so I can either
give a different give a different
example or who would like to see an
example of writing a table driven test
table-driven test Forge hands who would
like to see other than a table driven
test saying um given given you you can
you can read the rest of it you can read
the rest of it I do want to go through
the the table driven test exercise
because it it gives a lot of examples on
how to how do how do it's tailored and
tests are quite a neat thing in go
because they let you add test cases very
quickly so speaking quickly we have a
split function it just splits strings on
separators how do we write a test for
that everyone knows that test split we
have what we got what we expected we
probably use something like DP costs a
are they're the same
the next question is well okay we've
written it written one test do what
what's the coverage watch the coverage
of that well it turns out you can use
built-in coverage tool that comes and go
that gives you you passed - cover
profile which writes out a little a
little file about what it did and you
can expect that later on with go to a
cover function that gives you the
coverage per function so this just gives
you an overall summary and this breaks
it down by function this is not a very
exciting example there aren't many
branches so there's good coverage I use
this so often that I have this is this
is a bash a list that I have which
basically does the same two things there
so in any in any package
yeah Mike Mike gopath is completely
messed up because of the demos lost
during last week I can't show you that
but you can imagine that gives you the
coverage actually I'll just do it in a
different policy
Oh yep you get you know with one
commander coat so that's basically the
way I run my tests all the time I just
type cover and look look at my coverage
so now we have one test we've got good
good coverage but given there are many
branches we probably need to test some
boundary conditions like what happens if
we split on the wrong separator what
happens if we split the string in there
isn't a separator and so we end up with
so we now have three test cases they
look about the same but the thing is
that there's a lot of duplication in
there like every single thing with the
exception of the input the output and
the name portion of the test is the same
like that that's that's a lot to
copypasta especially if you discover
that maybe maybe you want to slightly
change that like like the the check
logic is is repeated and you have to do
that many times it's a large application
now there's wonderful tradition called
table-driven tests and I do not know the
other than it started in the standard
library I do not know the the originator
of this is this kind of form we make it
make a type called a test we fill it up
with test fixtures for the input we the
input we want the output we expect and
then we just loop over them so we've
consolidated all of the well it used to
be those very repetitive test functions
into one one test case so these are
different fixtures for the split
function
and in fact we can try this up a little
bit more that because we're declaring
this tests variable at the local scope
like we want to probably call inside
functions for different kind of
functions not split want to reuse the
structure again we declare all that
stuff locally we can use a this form to
both declare it and initialize it at the
same time so now adding new test cases
like for example what happens if there's
a trailing separator is just a matter of
just adding fixtures to this table it's
free it's very clear what's happening
all of this stuff is related to the
split function
okay so now now it turns out that
test-case didn't pass there's a that
brings into the into a few things that
we need to talk about the first one is
it just says expected ABC got a slightly
different ABC where did that come from
which test case failed because we moved
away from having one test per function
we've lost the name so a bunch of you'll
see a bunch of styles because it's very
much an area that is still evolving but
the first thing is that because this is
a slice well we can use the index of the
slice so here we say test I plus one
expected got and now when we run it at
least says test case number four I
expected this
I got that that's better than nothing
but you saw we had to do it like a
little bit of fudging because the slices
are zero based and this is one base and
like humans want to count in one like
when we think of test case number four
it also means that we need to be
consistent like across all the test
cases that you are all the tests
fixtures that you ride across all the
packages in your code across your
company needs to be some standardization
on are we zero based or are with one
base for our test codes test cases
so perhaps a better pattern is we can
recover the name Babel this is just a
struct we can put fields in there so
let's just put a name in there then if
the test case fails we can print out the
name
that's better it's going to give us
something to search on to find also
recovers that comment that was
previously lost because it's just a
comment it's not printed out anywhere
the previous example using using the
test index requires you to do a lot of
kind of brace matching like you've got
really big fixtures maybe really hard to
figure out what is number four like if
it's a really some really complicated
some complicated fixtures I can show you
some of the some of the test cases from
my project long long long
like very detailed kind of data
structures so finding the fourth data
structure entry could be quite
complicated so using your name is quite
good and then we can this this is the
final form this is this is one that Mike
Mitchell Hashimoto users and I I credit
him with being the first first one to do
it that which is realizing that well
name is really a key a key to this test
so instead of using a slice we can use a
map this is the map of test case names
to this anonymous structure of test
fixtures this has got one other very
useful property his map iteration order
is undefined I'm just gonna say random
because it's easier we don't have that
argument and and the reason this is
super useful is it means that now your
test cases are not run in the same order
all the time so you can spot when your
test cases are not hygienic because a
change some state and B is testing that
state that's being changed if you run
them run them out of order now a sudden
the test cases can't rely on that and it
lets you pick up some stuff where where
the test cases are not emetic so it's
really good to run them run them out of
order
now there there are two other through
two other problems the first one is that
we're calling T dot fatal so in this
loop the first test that fails T dot
fatal is going to cancel is going to
print out this liner than exit the test
case this is one of the use uses of
non-local return that panic is used for
in the standard library to let until
that test case is basically bailout the
problem with that is what if we're
refactoring and we break all the tests
make make a big mistake this is only
going to print one entry so the first
one that fails and it's going to be an
undefined which one it actually is he's
going to is going to print out so if
you're doing a refactoring and you make
a break it's not clear whether you've
broken one test will you broken all of
them and you're just seeing the first so
what we want is now we could use T dot
error which marks our test has failed
but continues the execution the problems
with that are when you do that the your
test
now-now-now you failed at this point if
you had several other cases in your test
case you need to be very careful that
you don't accidentally execute into
those when the first one has failed
where you see T dot error used in ten
tests you often find that these tests
are work great when everything passes
but when there's a test failure they
become incredibly fragile they don't
just report an error within an
immediately panic afterwards so T dot
error is kind of it is it's kind of a
smell these days because we now have the
wonderful thing called sub tests
now subtest gives us back the ability to
have one function per test like we
passed an anonymous function so we can
fight laugh as much as we want it just
cancels this inner block rather than the
outer block which means we recover we
can print all the failing sub tests
without having to write any special
special clever logic the other one is
that they have really good names their
name isn't just a string in the output
it's actually part of the test name
because this is built into the testing
framework so we can even run a subset of
a particular tests cases
by passing in this regex
so it's gonna say run any-any subtests
called trailing so we've got back all
the behavior that we had prior when we
wrote each test case individually with a
lot of duplication as well as having
this is very simple way add test cases
you'll see this used a lot it is the it
is the majority of the way of writing
tests and go certainly in the standard
library because it's it's such a
low-impact way of just adding new
fixtures as you find test cases and
combined with fuzzing which gives you
adversarial inputs which you can turn
into test cases this is a really good
way of improving your coverage and your
confidence in your code very very very
quickly
now the last thing the very very last
thing I'm going to talk about and this
is the last error I mentioned is now
we've got this failing test case we've
finished messing with the the framework
or the Tecna test harness I've actually
got to fix the test case what's the
problem here they're not the same
reflexes they're not the same obviously
people with good eyes can spot there's
an extra space at the end there we don't
know where it came from but believe me
if this is not a simple comparing two
slices of strings but to complicated
structures together that one little
space in there is going to be very very
hard to spot so an easy way to perhaps a
way to improve this would be to use
percent hash fee which is a special kind
of formatting font formatting verb that
says printed out in a gouache
declaration it's not you can't directly
copy and paste it back in but it looks a
lot closer so expected a slice of string
a and B and C got slice of string a and
B and C and an empty string on the end
so it's very clear what happened there
and this works for simple inputs but
rarely are your input simple and to give
give an example of where percent V does
not work
let's take a look at let's take a look
at this we have type T just as a field
called I and X is a slice of pointers to
tier 1 tier 2 tier 3 Y is a slice of
tier 1 tier 2 and tier 4 so obviously
they're not the same because the values
of I in those slices are not the same
now if we use percent V as we expect
it's just going to tell us that pointer
addresses but unfortunately percent hash
fee can't do any better
it tells it's in a more verbose kind of
way like this memory address is a
pointer to a t but it can't tell us the
thing we need to know which is the
insight what the value of I inside that
team so turns out percent hash fee not
actually a success it's okay for small
cases but when the comparisons get very
obvious it get very complicated it kind
of falls down and this is what I meant
by you might start off with a simple
simple test case you might think
I think oh this is final I never I never
have to change these bits here I can
just copy and paste this over time but
then later on you find that oh I need to
start using percent V for some of these
cases and then later on if I need to do
inspect them a bit more and so each of
the test cases which you said were just
like don't look at that that's not the
active part each becomes slightly
different so that's another reason for
using a table different tests that you
can consolidate your logic so the final
thing I'm going to introduce you to is
something that I've been using a lot and
it really it really is the darks guts
this is Joe sighs Joe C&P library it is
specifically designed as a replacement
to reflect our DP DP core it's it kind
of it it has more capabilities to define
what equality means it can deal with
very complicated situations you can tell
it to ignore certain fields it follows
Joe's personal bias that you shouldn't
use DP equals on private fields and it's
very very picky about that so obviously
you can use it where you'd use reflect
up deep equals are x and y equal false
of course known or not but where it
really pays for itself is the diff
function and the diff function is the
whole tamale this returns you a textual
def of what is different between x and y
it doesn't just tell you they're not the
same it tells you exactly where they're
different and this this is this is worth
the price of admission
for example in this case no it's not the
it's a syntax only a mother could love
but it says this is a slice of tea at
index two so the third position the
value was I I was expecting a three and
I got a four you do need to kind of
learn it's learn its language but the
thing is it's very consistent in the way
that it does this and once you learn
learn how to interpret that it tells you
exactly what was different
rather than somehow printing out all of
these inputs and all these outputs and
believe me when this input is not a
slice of three pointers to tea but a
huge G RPC structures like enormous G
RPC structures that you have to tell the
difference between one field somewhere
and there is different this pays for
itself so the conclusion is bringing in
bringing in go CMP using you say do a
difference sometimes you have to pass
some option structures for things like
if you want it if you want it to not not
compare some fields or if you want it to
deal with with types that have private
fields you need to pass those options
there but it gets only one line in your
test case and then you just say if the
diff is not blank
if something is different then we fail
and just print out that diff and so here
again it's it unfortunately
this example turned out to me not the
world's most most clearest but it's
saying this slice of string at the at
the fourth element so the previous one
had did nothing had nothing at three
this one has a three this was
non-existent this one had his face so
it's saying there are different size and
not only are they different size but the
value in that that was not expected is
actually is rather not being present
into space
so with that I am I'm gonna close I'm we
didn't get through everything I'm I
didn't really expect to even if I just
sat and read 20,000 words you at a
monotone I couldn't do it in four hours
anyway but as I said this all of this
material is yours to read to use to
refute to discuss what whatever you want
these are my experiences right and go
over the last five or six years and we
can close I think on a few questions we
do have to get out of here because it's
5:30
but with that we'll take any final
questions or if you're coming to the
conference tomorrow you can buttonhole
me there if you're coming to the sorry
not not on Friday if you come to the
conference on Friday you can buttonhole
me there I'd love to have to talk to you
about any questions usually the answers
are longer than the longer than the
question because we really are kind of
discussing subjective things like the
the final goal is better clearer more
readable go code and there is no hard
and fast rule it's always so it's a set
of informed decisions driven by
experience so with that if there are one
or two questions and we might then we
might quit okay yes and then I'll take
the next question yes go ahead
so unit functions are affected war not
effectively they are global state let me
let me show you there is no difference
between there is no difference between
under the hood these generate the same
code they do the same thing so if you're
looking at in it functions are saying
these are weird these are unpredictable
all that applies equally to global
variables if you if you believe what
Peter Bergen is saying and I definitely
subscribe to his view you shouldn't have
global state you shouldn't have any
functions they fought for all the
reasons that that global state is bad
it's a singleton it's hard to test it's
hard to replicate because it because
everyone knows its name they can change
it on you it creates tight coupling
between packages and I think perhaps
your difficulties within it functions
are a symptom of that like the it's not
the inner function is weird to know
about which order they care about that
they're called in it's that you're
depending on some global state being set
at a particular time that's what that
that's all that's always that that the
trick Robert Martin says mutable
variables to know the state of immutable
variable first of all you need to know
what time it is
and when you when you face this when you
face the problem like that before I know
what I know what value what the contents
of this variable are I need to know what
time it is it's it's clear that there's
it's clear that there is an ordering
problem if I'm too early it'll have a
different value sorry that is possibly
the worst not answer I've ever given
other than to say
you my advice would be you would you
really really need to limit you in it
variables you would really need to limit
the use of them because they're
symptomatic of global state which is the
the fundamental problem so question over
there you just put on your hand yes okay
the the difference between a library and
an application mote most of most of the
differences certainly in the past have
come down to how you think about your
dependency management when you're a
library you're going to be mixed in with
other code and so so you have three
different three three three different
libraries that depend that also depend
on a logging library so they're all
going to be mixed they're all going to
be mixed together with that log in
dependency in the final application is
going to be one one version that logging
library they all have to work against it
so as a library developer it used to be
extremely difficult to first of all
specify any of any information about the
version of the dependency you're using
or you could say all you knew was from
the import line I this program needs
logrus somewhere to be there there was
no way in the import line to say this
version of logrus there was no way in
libraries to specify I have a transitive
dependency on Lagos as fortunates got a
lot better this is getting a lot better
in depth and got a lot better and go
modules now from the point of view of an
application the application owns all the
dependencies it's the one that should
declare we use this version of blog rest
in this version of the XML parsing
library and this version of the JSON
library in this version of G RPC the
application developer is I think
actually in a much easier position when
it comes to when it comes to writing go
programs like you can be very strict to
give you an example of how well the
vendor folder all the dependencies that
your program needs you kept a copy of
them in the vendor folder you could you
don't need to but you could keep a copy
of them in the vendor folder vendor
folders in libraries
were extremely problematic because when
you bring a bunch of libraries together
with their independent vendor folders
you must collapse them down onto a
single one that was an insoluble problem
the reason why we have DEP now go
modules that there are a moves removes
the vendor folder so to step back and
answer that answer that more concisely
writing applications ago is pretty
straightforward even if you have
multiple dependencies writing a library
and go and having it reliably mix able
be mixed into into a larger application
was pretty difficult when all we have
let's go get it's certainly getting a
lot better
Glide go DEP and go and go modules make
it more tractable to actually as a
library writer to say my thing works
with can only be mixed into projects
that have dependencies between these
ranges so is that is that an answer like
like I'm speaking mainly for my
experience of not necessarily writing
the library but how they interact in the
bigger ecosystem of other people using
them Sara
you're writing from library's movie was
actually local
from from the point of an application
about but you have you you have the
ability to say my program needs exactly
these versions for the point of view of
a library developer if you say I can
only be build against these versions you
make it very hard to be to be mixed into
another program so you usually have
specified version ranges and while
that's a well understood concept until
until god till go to Epping modules we
didn't actually have any tools to do
that it was very difficult and that's
why a lot of I'm gonna make a subjective
statement here but my observation is
that go packages did not tend to have
very go libraries did not tend to have
very deep dependency chains because it
was actually impossible for a library
writer to cleanly say I only work
against did did this downstream
dependency so my answer is mainly many
phrased around tooling rather than
rather than any kind of specific coding
style or something like that about about
writing a library maybe maybe one or two
more questions yes
how is package eras what's up how is how
is the XRS package um I'll refer you to
don't hey this'll do refer to this
document the the super short summary is
the error values is that and that this
is the contentious part values returned
from errors new or from tower F will
actually now contain the stack frame in
which they were called so they they help
they now know where they came from the
contentious part is not so much that but
how that information is printed out
that's what people are getting very
upset about but if you're used used to
the fact the errors package or the
number of others that put a stack frame
wrap a stack frame around another error
that logic is being brought up streaming
to the ghost standard library this is
the this is the one you want to look at
the
somewhere in there which I can't find
immediately is the
throughout there are somewhere somewhere
in these listed the actual issue numbers
for all the discussion is happening but
this this bigger page is linked from the
go blog it doesn't make that bigger go
to draft and so this is the reference to
the three proposals there's this this
more stuff there but basically start
with that one more question than a we've
definitely cleaning up last question
once twice oh yes yes I haven't actually
played with the eros package because
fundamentally I'm still on 112 for my
project I can't really use it use it
Nanga with my date with my day job until
until it actually gets there I've talked
a lot to my cell we ran into each other
on the road the underlying the
underlying design is this the the the
same the same is there and I want to be
very clear that's the era's packet the
error package that I wrote is really
just another reinterpretation of about
three or four of them we wrote a
canonical and many others that other
people doing so I'm not saying that I
this is my idea in fact lean OTT all I
did was all I did was just apply my
logic of let's get rid of as many
parameters as we could to make it as
simple and dumb to use as possible
the other answer I can give to you is
that when something is incorporated
upstream into the into into the NGO
standard library there is no value in me
maintaining the eros package other than
to provide a path for people to migrate
to the standard library no-go
programmers are served by there being a
competition for yet another errors
package so I the value I see in my
errors package that I wrote is to
socialize the ideas which have been
picked up by by the by the go team and
again these are not my ideas these are
ones that just been flow floating around
it around enough if anything I was just
lucky that I was a smart aleck and
managed to snap the pkg project name on
github that's probably the thing that
made it more popular than others it's
just shorter that's all but this is the
fear that they what this this is the
future like like the what's what's going
into go is what is what we should use
this is there is no value from having a
competing standard anymore but the the
value in terms of showing the go team
that this is a real-world usage and
there's actually real value to get from
having stack traces has been made it's
going into the standard library and with
that as Valentine Valentine here do you
want to close out yeah do you do you
have any closing thoughts do is there
any information for people for later in
the week should we get out should we
pull the fire alarm on the way out like
what should we do
yes I guess it's yen right I mean feel
free to stay around till like 6:00